Tim Ferriss: Dr. Attia, Peter, nice to see
you.
Dr. Peter Attia: Good to see you, man.
Tim Ferriss: I wanted to start with the personal,
we're going to get into all sorts of topics,
many different aspects of your practice, lessons
learned, et cetera but I went to your house
recently.
We had some Topo Chico and a bite to eat and
a few other things.
And I commented on how much larger you were
and not larger as in obese, but muscularly
larger.
So I thought we would begin with the question
of how and why, not necessarily in that order,
you added so much muscle mass.
Dr. Peter Attia: In the fall of 2021, I had
sort of hit a relative low in weight that
wasn't quite as low as where I was as a cyclist,
which was probably about 165 pounds, but was
still pretty low for me in the maybe mid-low
to mid 170s.
And I did a DEXA scan, which I do periodically,
probably a couple times a year, but I hadn't
done one in a few years.
And when I get my DEXA scan, I always plot
the data.
So I'm not just interested in body fat, but
also bone mineral content and many other metrics.
But one of them that's really important is
something called Appendicular Lean Mass Index
or ALMI.
Another one is called FFMI, Fat-Free Mass
Index.
And it's probably worth explaining a little
bit about what these are, but the ALMI takes
what the DEXA scan imputes as the lean tissue
in your arms and legs in kilograms divides
that by your height in meters squared.
So it spits out a number like eight kilograms
per meter squared.
This is a pretty accurate representation of
how much muscle you have in your arms and
legs because the DEXA scan can really only
identify three things, bone fat and other.
And since things in your arms that are not
bone and fat tend to be muscle, it's pretty
good at identifying muscle, whereas the Fat-Free
Mass Index looks at the entire body and just
subtracts out fat.
That's also a good proxy for lean mass, but
there are many other things like organs that
are taking up some residents there.
Anyway, when I looked at these metrics, I
was shocked.
I was shocked at how much less muscle I had
than 10 years earlier, almost exactly 10 years
sooner.
And I attribute it to several things, but
I really thought that chief among them was
just how much fasting I had been doing over
the previous three years.
I had really kind of taken fasting to a pretty
extreme place doing up to 10 days of water
only, and routinely just busting out seven-day
water-only fasts, certainly doing three days
every month would be something I would do
without hesitation.
Tim Ferriss: When you say 10 days of water
only, over what period of time is that?
Dr. Peter Attia: Meaning how frequently would
I do that?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm just wondering what
the cadence was if we take it as a minimal
—
Dr. Peter Attia: Probably quarterly.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, probably every quarter.
And while I certainly think there are some
benefits from doing that, I think what I was
sort of confronting was, wow, there's actually
a pretty big cost as well.
And I would go out of my way while fasting
to still exercise.
I was lifting weights every single day, which
was difficult sometimes, but doing everything
I could to try to stimulate muscle protein
synthesis.
But at the end of the day, if you're not providing
any nutrients, including amino acids, you're
basically just tearing down muscle to try
to rebuild with that muscle.
But your net effect is a loss.
So I kind of just said, "I've got to fix this.
I've got to do something about this, and I
want to have my ALMI be in at least the 90th
percentile, if not above the 97th percentile
as I age."
The data are pretty unambiguous that people
live longer, better lives with an ALMI north
of the 75th percentile.
So not one to just clear the bar, I want to
be considerably above the bar.
So basically I just changed things around
and said, "Nutrition and exercise are going
to change a little bit," so we can talk about
those changes, but basically I've made big
changes with exercise and nutrition to make
those corrections.
Tim Ferriss: How much lean mass did you gain
over what period of time would you say once
making these changes?
Dr. Peter Attia: So in a span of, oh, God,
I'd have to go back and look at the exact
data, I believe it was 13 or 14 pounds of
lean mass in about 12 months.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
And what were —
Dr. Peter Attia: Which is, again, that's not
Herculean, right?
These are not insane numbers, not taking anabolic
steroids, this is relatively doable for someone
who is making it a high priority to eat the
right amount of protein, the right kind of
protein, and spacing it and consuming it at
the right times, and then also focusing, training
on a little more hypertrophy.
Tim Ferriss: So for people listening, I'm
asking these questions not simply because
I'm interested in lean mass, but also the
implications for longevity.
So I'm guessing you did not put all of that
lean muscle on your biceps and that there
were other movements that were incorporated
for very particular reasons if I'm getting
my read on Dr. Peter Attia, right as I think
I am.
So perhaps you could just describe some of
those changes and also protein and how you
suggest people think about protein, how you
began thinking about protein.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, I'll start with that
and then we can talk about the training.
So the protein basically went to a very conscious
and concerted effort to increase protein to
one gram per pound of body weight.
People are going to ask, "Is that one pound
of actual body weight?
Is that one pound of lean body weight?
Is that one pound of target body weight?"
The answer is for someone my size and weight
and my body fat percentage, I think at the
time I was about 15 percent body fat, it really
doesn't matter.
It could be basically, call it one pound of
current body weight, one gram per pound of
current body weight is sufficient.
So that's what I did.
The next question that becomes timing.
And this is something that right until a couple
years ago, I wasn't really paying enough attention
to.
So it wasn't enough to just say, "Well, Peter,
you've got to have 180 grams of protein in
a day," because for example, 290 gram bolus
of protein doesn't accomplish nearly the same
thing as 445 gram servings spread out over
the course of a day.
So there is kind of a sweet spot with protein
where you really need to be north of about
20 to 25 grams to ensure that those amino
acids aren't just going into what's called
a gluconeogenic pathway.
So we can turn protein into glucose, but we
don't really want to, protein should be thought
of as a structural nutrient, whereas we want
to really think of carbohydrates and fats
as energy nutrients.
So you have to have enough protein in a given
serving that you don't just have the liver
take it and use its bit for gluconeogenesis.
At the same time you don't want to have too
much and too much is a bit of an unclear limit,
but my best reading of the literature is that
you're starting to hit too much at about 50
grams in a serving.
Tim Ferriss: And what type of protein are
we talking about just in terms of, I'm thinking
of bioavailability and so on, and kind of
protein efficiency ratio.
What type of protein, how should people think
about quality or type of protein?
Dr. Peter Attia: So the first decision I think
everybody wants to make is, am I getting this
from plant or animal?
And again, unfortunately, this has become
sort of a contentious topic and it's got its
sort of political religious overtones to it.
But if you don't concern yourself with any
of those things and you just think about biochemistry,
there's really no ambiguity here.
Protein derived from animal sources are more
bioavailable.
So you can overcome some of that by cooking
the plant.
So once you start to cook the plant and free
it up from the fiber, you can liberate more
of the plant protein, but you're still always
going to be struggling with a bit of a bioavailability
problem.
That can be anywhere from a 20 percent to
30 percent haircut, you're taking just on
the net consumption of the amino acid.
The second issue comes down to amino acid
quality.
And if you're really concerning yourself with
hypertrophy, I think the three most important
amino acids would be leucine, lysine, and
methionine.
And these are amino acids that also you don't
tend to have as high a quantity in plant protein.
Now you can get them, and it gets especially
hard if you can't have dairy or eggs.
So if someone says, "Look, I'm a vegetarian,
I'm not going to eat beef or chicken, but
I'm willing to have eggs and dairy," it gets
a lot easier.
Eggs, for example, are a very high source
of methionine.
So what we typically will tell patients is
rather than just fixating on the total number
of grams of protein you need to eat, which
you may have a hard time hitting, if you focus
on the number of grams of leucine, lycine,
and methionine you're getting in a given meal
or a given day, that will almost assuredly
get your total protein quantity to the right
place.
So for me, that really meant, I just wanted
to make sure I was getting, gosh, probably
six to eight grams of leucine a day, comparable
amount of lysine, at least two grams of methionine
a day.
And I use an app to track what I'm eating
just so that I can see where my protein is
coming from and how much I'm getting and when
and where and that tended to work out pretty
well.
Tim Ferriss: What is the name of the app if
you're willing to mention it?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, it's called Carbon.
I have no affiliation with it, but a friend
of mine, it's his app and I like it.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Dr. Peter Attia: I guess my affiliation is
that it's my friend's app.
Tim Ferriss: I'm glad you brought up the leucine,
lysine, and methionine, because I was going
to ask earlier if while you were fasting,
but losing lean muscle mass over time, you
were supplementing with say, branch chain
amino acids in any fashion.
Dr. Peter Attia: I was.
I used to always drink BCAAs during workouts
and for folks listening, there were three
branch chain amino acids.
And leucine is hands down the most relevant
of them and we know from work that our mutual
friend David Sabatini has done in his lab
that leucine is a very, very potent mTOR stimulator.
In fact, it might be the single most potent
stimulator of mTOR, mTOR, of course, acutely,
you want that thing stimulated.
It's promoting growth.
You don't want it chronically stimulated,
but you want it acutely stimulated.
The problem with branch chain amino acids,
and I've got to tell you, Tim, I think it's
largely fallen out of favor.
So I don't even consume branch chain amino
acids anymore.
When I'm during a workout, I'm literally just
consuming like an electrolyte drink.
That's it.
The problem is, one, they don't stick around
long enough and they're free form, and two,
you're just not getting enough of them.
The third thing is the temporal nature of
when you take them in being in the workout
or couple hours after the workout doesn't
really seem to matter, our window in which
we can synthesize new muscle is sufficiently
broad that even for an untrained individual
who has a narrower window, it's totally reasonable
to say, look, just make sure a couple hours
after that workout, you get in your big protein
meal.
So instead, today I just use high-quality
whey protein post-workout, and I don't trouble
myself with consuming any protein in workout.
Tim Ferriss: So I just want to mention a few
things for folks.
So number one, there's a huge difference between
no animal products and lacto-ovo vegetarian.
And one example of that would be Bill Pearl,
who became Mr. Universe as a lacto-ovo vegetarian.
So it does make a huge difference.
The second I'll just mention, we may come
back to this and discuss keto at some point,
we have discussed it at length in previous
conversations, but the gluconeogenesis is
one of, well, is I suppose the pathway by
which you can knock yourself out of keto if
you consume too much protein and not enough
fat.
Liver just loves to convert that into glucose
and then bada bing, bada boom, you're out
of ketosis, or at least out of sort of the
range that one would be aiming for.
So let's come to the book.
So you and I have had many offline conversations
about the book.
We'll probably not repeat some of them.
Why did it take so long?
And I believe there were three iterations
over six years, and the first iteration had
a zero translation into the final version.
Something along those lines, maybe you could
correct me if I'm getting that wrong, but
why have you taken so much time to work on
this book?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, it's a really good
question, Tim.
I think there are probably several factors,
some of which are related, some of which are
not.
I think on one level, my appetite for how
"good" I needed this book to be was very high.
And I say that with no —
Tim Ferriss: So unlike like you, Peter.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look, I think there are some people out there
who can churn out a book a year, and more
power to them.
But the way I viewed this book was that this
is sort of the one and only book I ever want
to write.
Will I ever write another book?
It's hard for me to ever imagine the answer
to that question is yes, but again, maybe
at the end of my life I'll have something
else to say.
As I'm 50 years old now and I'm at the midpoint
of my life or slightly past the midpoint of
my life, I feel like everything I ever want
to say on this particular topic is in this
book.
And therefore, it was just a very long book.
I mean, the final version is probably 140,000
words.
The version I ultimately submitted was 200,000
This has been chopped way down by 30 percent
into what is still obviously a book that is
quite long.
So that's part of it.
I also think part of it is, and maybe you
can relate to this, Tim, I don't know, we've
never actually talked about this, but I think
there's just a vulnerability that comes with
writing in this manner that is unlike all
the writing I've done in the past.
So I've been blogging insanely for 12 years,
that's different.
You're not really putting yourself out there
when you write a blog post.
You don't have to read the comments that people
write.
You don't have to pay attention to any of
that stuff.
I think when you write a book, you are really
saying to people like, "Here I am, tear me
down."
And I just think there's, on some level, maybe
it's embarrassing to say this, there's just
been a little bit of a reluctance to be that
again, for lack of a better word, vulnerable,
just to sort of say, "Okay, I'm willing to
say everything I have to say on a subject
matter and now let the arrows come flying."
And that's, again, I don't know that that
makes sense, but I'm sure that anyone who
does something very public feels that way.
But it's different with podcasting, which
I don't have a problem doing, and it's different
with blogging, which I don't have a problem
doing.
But this strikes me as maybe what an actor
feels like when they make a big film or a
director, or again, like an author like you.
So I think there was a little bit of subconscious
dragging my feet and hey, maybe I can just
keep working on this book forever, but it'll
never actually come out.
Tim Ferriss: So I do identify, and I would
say for me at least, part of that is when
you put out a book, it might be one of the
20 books the publisher's working on that season,
but especially if it's a book of this depth
and also I will second vulnerability, not
just on the personal side when discussing
physical health, but also in the chapter or
as a dissection really on mental health, psychoemotional
health, and so on, I mean, you really show
sides of yourself that are uncommonly shown,
I think in some of your other formats.
And unlike a blog post, it's very hard to
just delete a book from the world once it
is published.
So I, number one, think it was right to take
it seriously.
And however long it takes to do a book of
this quality is the time that it takes.
And I think that's the way it should be.
And I will say, just as a side note, and I
mentioned this to you and you know this, that
my dad, who has struggled in various ways
with health for decades now, picked up your
book, which I had at home when he was visiting
me in Austin and could not put it down.
I won't get into all the details of why this
is the case, but if that isn't a testimonial,
I cannot imagine what is to the extent that
I ended up giving him my copy so he could
take it home.
So that should tell everybody.
Dr. Peter Attia: I didn't know that, Tim,
thank you.
Because when you guys came over, he mentioned
how much he was liking it.
He had just picked it up, but I didn't realize
he'd finished it and he enjoyed it, so thank
you.
That means a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, definitely.
And with that, let's talk about perhaps this
is a good place to start, objective, strategy,
tactics.
Why are these three pillars important, and
why all three?
Dr. Peter Attia: I learned about this stuff
about a decade ago when I was working on a
problem that is irrelevant now, but I think
the message was important, which was, I think
I had a vague sense of what the objective
was, and my immediate tendency, which I think
is normal, and I think we all do, because
I don't think anyone's hardwired to go through
the middle step, was to go from objective
to tactics.
In fact, I think most people just kind of
go to tactics without even thinking about
objective.
And certainly not having that strategy piece
in the middle makes life really complicated.
So the first thing, I think, is to understand
what's the difference.
So objective is pretty straightforward.
It needs to be stated.
It should be very clear, though.
So for example, my objective might be to live
longer.
If you said, "Well, what are the tactics now?
What should I eat?
How should I exercise?
Do I need to take this supplement or that
supplement?"
The probability that you are going to come
up with the right set of instructions is vanishingly
small.
It's somewhere between zero.
Tim Ferriss: Even if provided this list, this
laundry list of tactics.
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, I guess the question
is how do you come up with the list?
Are you filtering on that list?
Right?
So there's no shortage of tactics that one
could think about because the world is rife
with everybody offering their tactics.
But it's not like I'm not suggesting tactics,
but what I really want people to do is say,
"Look, let's anchor to a strategy."
So for example, if one of your objectives
is, "Okay, I'm going to live longer," it's
like, no, let's deconstruct that.
What does living longer mean?
Well, to understand what it means to live
longer, you have to understand what ends life.
Well, what ends life is a very clear and easy-to-understand
dataset so let's look at it and let's look
at it in great detail.
We call this the death bars analysis.
So what are the death bars?
Well, it turns out if you're over 40, you
don't smoke, we can really clearly tell you
that there's about an 80 percent chance you're
going to die from atherosclerotic cardiovascular
disease, cancer, neurodegenerative disease,
or metabolic diseases such as type two diabetes
and things like that.
Probably I would include accidental death
in there, so falling or automotive accidents.
So that's an important insight because now
you start to work backwards from there.
So wait a minute.
You think, oh, if I want to live longer, I
have to avoid those things.
Okay, how do I avoid those things?
Well, let's start with the chronic disease
bucket.
There's two ways to think about that, right?
I love when things turn into somewhat binary
decisions, is one way to live longer, to live
longer with a chronic disease or live longer
without a chronic disease.
So might not be entirely obvious which of
those is true, but if we look at the data,
it's pretty clear.
The data unambiguously make it clear that
you will live longer if you can extend the
period of time that you live without a chronic
disease, rather than extend the period of
time you have the chronic disease.
So in other words, it's better to get cancer
later in life than to live longer with cancer
as one example.
It's better to have your first heart attack
very late in life than have it early in life,
and then be right on the verge of having another
one as time goes on.
Well, just by going through those very simple
questions, all of a sudden you start to formulate
a much clearer strategy for living longer
that points you much more clearly towards
this idea I talked about in the book called
Medicine 3.0 rather than Medicine 2.0.
And once you iron all that out, then you start
to get into the tactics.
Oh, all right.
Okay.
So how does nutrition layer onto this?
How does pharmacology layer onto this?
How does exercise layer onto this, et cetera.
Tim Ferriss: I want to just share an anecdote,
which will not surprise you, but when I published
The 4-Hour Body, and no doubt you're going
to get a lot of these types of requests if
you haven't already, I had a number of, not
morbidly obese, but out-of-shape CEO friends
say, "Look, I just want the index card.
Just give me the index card with the seven
things I should do, and I'll do those seven
things."
Can you guess what the compliance rate was
with that, Peter?
What's your guess?
Dr. Peter Attia: Very close to the success
rate of skipping the strategy step.
Tim Ferriss: Zero percent.
Not a single one of them actually implemented
any of it.
And just as a quick side note, which you might
entertaining, I had an amazing mega-successful
investor named Ed Thorpe on the podcast, if
not over 90, 90 right now, he's in excellent
shape and he plans his travel around minimizing
time in automobiles.
And he's sort of run through the numbers just
as an anecdote.
Dr. Peter Attia: Very underappreciated, very
underappreciated cause of morbidity and mortality.
Yeah, I think about it a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
We might come back to as I think about a different
seat belts that you can use in life, which
initially, I don't want to turn this into
a Tim Ferriss TED Talk, but initially thought
about with respect to COVID early, which was
like what minimally inconvenient, easy-to-do
things can you do to dramatically mitigate
risk.
So even though you've never had a head-on
collision, the downside of having a head-on
collision is so high that most of us will
wear a seatbelt when driving on the highway.
Most of us will have a fire extinguisher in
the kitchen even though there's never been
a fire in your kitchen, et cetera.
So where else can we take very small steps
that are easy, low cost, that prevent dramatic
downside risk?
But so we may come back to that, but I want
to bring up a graph that you have in your
book, page 28 for those who want to find it,
where if you remove the top eight contagious/infectious
diseases, meaning we're accounting for the
advent of antibiotics, at least as I understand
it.
We haven't really seen a material or at least
large change in mortality rates since what,
1900 if you sort of account for some of these
variables.
Why do you think that is?
Because certainly most people don't want to
die.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
So you're absolutely right.
So life expectancy since 1900 to today, has
increased by twofold.
It's remarkable.
It's gone from about 40 to about 80 plus or
minus, but that's directionally the change
we've seen in, call it 120 years.
And I do think that understandably, it's tempting
to tout that as the marvels of modern medicine.
And you're thinking, well, oh, my God, we
went from 40 to 80 in 120 years, the next
40 just based on Moore's Law, that's got to
get us to like 160, right?
Okay, maybe.
But let's take a closer look at the data.
So you do this very simple analysis, which
is, okay, let's go back to 1900 and march
forward.
But when we go through the mortality tables,
just strip out the top eight leading infectious
disease causes of death.
And what you see is exactly what you describe.
There is now no change in mortality from then
until now effectively.
There's a little bit, it's been a little bit
better.
And I think what it speaks to is two things.
One is the remarkable success of Medicine
2.0 in solving acute care and infectious diseases,
and the remarkable failure of Medicine 2.0
in addressing the chronic diseases that sat
under the surface of the water waiting for
the tide to go down.
Tim Ferriss: And those would be presumably
the four or five likely causes that you mentioned
earlier.
Perhaps this is a good place for you just
to define or describe briefly, not Web 2.0,
try that again, for you to describe medicine
— I'm not going to be the only interviewer
who fucks that up, Medicine 2.0 and Medicine
3.0.
Dr. Peter Attia: It's probably easiest to
just for the take completeness, start with
Medicine 1.0.
Medicine 1.0 was basically everything that
occurred prior to the transition period of
the late 17th century into the late 19th century.
So that 200-year period marks a transition
from when medicine had absolutely no basis
in science whatsoever.
So I mean, we can mock it now, but truthfully,
they didn't have a scientific method or a
scientific tool, so all they could do was
sort of think about the gods, think about
bad humours come up with the best rationalization
they had for what was going on.
In fact, arguably the most insightful thought
that occurred in Medicine 1.0 was thousands
of years ago on the part of Hippocrates, who
was the first to believe that diseases were
somehow caused by nature and not the gods.
That was truly a remarkable insight now, beyond
that, he had no clue what was going on, but
that was a remarkable insight, and that was
probably the apex of Medicine 1.0.
With Francis Bacon in the 17th century, we
had basically the first push towards the scientific
method.
This became really important, and no one has
done a better job explaining this than our
mutual hero, Richard Feynman.
There's a great video, which I'm sure you
guys can find for the show notes, where it's
an old grainy black and white where Feynman
is talking about the scientific method.
And he's saying, "Look, you make a guess,
right?
You design an experiment.
The guess is called a hypothesis, by the way,
it's just a fancy word for a guess.
You design an experiment to test that hypothesis.
You do the experiment.
You compare the results of the experiment
to your guess.
And then you decide to either discard or update
your hypothesis."
This was such a profound concept that it basically
propelled us into Medicine 2.0.
And the place where that shone greatest was
unquestionably in the world of microbacteria,
of microscopic organisms, so viruses and bacteria.
And so, again, it's a brutal, bloody slog
to go from Semmelweis to Koch to Lister.
But that transition effectively brought us
into the modern era where, hey, all of a sudden
doctors were washing their hands and not operating
on people with dirty hands.
And of course, eventually we had antibiotics
and eventually we had vaccines.
And taking smallpox and polio off the table
and reducing the mortality of influenza and
having antibiotics, all of that stuff had
such a profound impact on human health that
it cut mortality rate down by a half and doubled
our life expectancy in the process.
So now we're into the maturation of Medicine
2.0.
We saw these other amazing success stories.
I think the two most notable by far would
be Hepatitis C and HIV.
I mean, to think that we're at a point now
where a virus that is as tricky as HIV can
basically be rendered a chronic disease on
the back of highly active antiretroviral therapy
is nothing short of amazing.
When I was in medical school, Tim, we're not
talking a long time ago, this is 25 years
ago, we were told Hep C will never be cured
and it will break the back of the US and global
transplant infrastructure, meaning we're going
to need so many livers to put into all these
people with Hep C that, by 2030, the system
will break.
And lo and behold, we have a drug that within
a matter of weeks will eradicate this thing.
So again, huge successes.
Now, counter that with what we've done against
cancer.
When Richard Nixon declared the War on Cancer,
before you and I were born, it was more than
50 years ago, the goal was to eradicate this
disease by the bicentennial in 1976.
Well, not only did that not happen, but here
we are more than 50 years later, and survival
for cancer is barely five percent greater
than it was in 1970.
I could go on and on, but let's just look
at neurodegenerative disease.
So you were talking about six million people
with Alzheimer's disease in this country.
If you add up those with Lewy body dementia
and Parkinson's disease, we're talking about,
gosh, another four and a half million.
So we're looking at more than 10 million people
in this country with very, very significant
neurodegenerative diseases.
And that says nothing about ALS and Huntington's
and things like that.
We don't have a single thing, like a single
thing that we can do to cure these people.
We have barely a few things that can slow
the progression of their diseases.
But we've made paltry steps against chronic
diseases.
When you and I were born, the prevalence of
type two diabetes was less than one percent.
Today it's 10 percent, effectively.
So we've seen a log fold increase in type
two diabetes. 100 to 120 million people in
the United States are metabolically sick,
meaning have metabolic syndrome or pre-diabetes,
or type two diabetes outright.
So something's not working.
And the current system of Medicine 2.0 doesn't
really seem equipped to address it.
It intervenes late, and by the time it's intervening,
it's not really fixing.
So this thing I'm proposing, this idea that
of course I'm not the first person to suggest,
maybe I'm the first person to talk about it
this way, is we want to pivot to this newer
way of thinking about things which deviates
from Medicine 2.0 in a couple of really important
areas.
The first is in its timeline.
So Medicine 2.0 is largely focused on treating
disease.
And it's really interesting when I think about
it, because it's so obvious that I can't believe
I didn't notice it earlier.
But when you're in medicine, when you're in
medical school, when you're in residency,
when you're in practice, you sort of need
a code for a disease.
You need a code for a disease that you bill
for and you treat.
And prevention doesn't really fit into that.
So when I went to medical school, I didn't
learn a single thing about nutrition or exercise
or sleep or stress management or emotional
health.
I learned a lot about pharmacology.
And it's tempting at this point to say, well,
pharmacology is either good or bad.
No, it's both, right?
Pharmacology is good and it's really valuable,
but over-indexing it is bad.
And ignoring all those other things is problematic.
Those other things turned out to be far more
efficient tools of prevention.
But if no doctor learned about them, then
why are we surprised that Medicine 2.0 is
unable to cope with that?
So one, we have to understand prevention,
and we have to understand the timeline for
prevention must start much sooner.
You have to start doing these things long
before diseases are ravaging the system.
The other big difference is that, as I talked
about it, the scientific method was such an
important part of Medicine 2.0, and with it
came something that I'm sure you've talked
about many times, which is the randomized
controlled experiment.
This is the tool that allowed us to do that
thing that Feynman described.
The randomized controlled experiment is really
wonderful.
It is insufficient by itself to solve the
problem.
So Medicine 3.0 needs to go from what we call
evidence-based medicine, you only do what
the randomized control trial says, to evidence-informed
medicine, which is, you take the insights
from the randomized control trials, but you
have to then modify them and specify them
to a given patient.
So those are really the huge leaps that we
have to take to now make this next transition.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say a bit more, expand
a bit, or give an example, hypothetical or
otherwise, of moving from the — I don't
want to say sole, but extremely strong focus
on only making decisions for patients based
on RCT data to what you're describing?
Dr. Peter Attia: Exercise is a great example.
So exercise would say, okay, the recommendations
would be to — I'm going to give you two
examples, by the way.
So this one's kind of a simpler one, and then
a more nuanced, sort of nerdier one.
But the nameplate recommendation around exercise
is something to the effect of two and a half,
three hours a week of moderately vigorous
activity.
But no one is parsing these data down and
actually looking at what metrics matter.
Like how much strength do you need to have
the absolute lowest risk in mortality?
How much cardiorespiratory performance do
you need to absolutely lower your risk, literally
fourfold, relative to someone in the bottom
quartile?
So do I have a randomized controlled experiment
that tells us that?
I don't.
No one's going to do that experiment, which
is, I'm going to take a group of 10,000 people,
randomize them to different levels of training,
increase each of their fitnesses to relative
levels, and follow them prospectively for
the remainder of their lives.
That experiment can't be done.
So instead, we have to be able to triangulate
between these other sources of data.
Another example, maybe a bit more glitchy,
might be the way we might use different forms
of lipid-lowering medication.
So this is kind of a whole other tangent we
could potentially dive into, which is if you're
really interested in preventing heart disease,
which by the way, number one cause of death
in men and women in the United States and
in the world, so it's the four-for-four champion
of death.
It's such the champion of death that for every
woman who dies of breast cancer, there's like
eight to 12 women who are dying of heart disease.
So pink ribbons matter; red ribbons matter
more.
This disease would be largely preventable
if people didn't smoke, controlled their blood
pressure, and had apoB levels that were equivalent
to the levels they had as children.
No one will do the clinical trial that will
get us there, yet we have all the Mendelian
randomization, we have all the mechanistic
data.
And so an evidence-based approach says, look,
we're going to target LDL cholesterol to 100
milligrams per deciliter.
This approach is going to say, actually, that's
probably insufficient for this individual
because their risks are higher, and by the
way, their appetite for reducing the risk
of this disease is higher.
So we're going to take a more aggressive posture,
even though the recommendation in the literature
is going to be far less aggressive.
Tim Ferriss: So Medicine 3.0 seems to comprise
a number of different elements, one of which
is early intervention or certainly much earlier
intervention, hence, early medical, I can
only imagine.
And another is medical literacy and a more,
perhaps, proactive approach to education and
intervention on the part of the patient.
So it's not a passive experience of being
shepherded through a system by a doctor or
a team of doctors.
You take a much more active role.
And I wanted to chat about medical literacy
because what I've noticed, just to give a
personal example, I long ago wanted to potentially
become a doctor and certainly became fascinated
by competitive sports and performance enhancement.
And that led to doing my best to read studies
and dig into the science and understand as
much as possible.
I was unsure of the value of that once I shifted
courses and decided to do other things.
But in the last, I would say, decade, as my
parents have gotten older, as more and more
of my friends have run into issues, it is
astonishing how valuable this minimum effective
dose of medical and scientific literacy has
become.
I mean, it's astonishing how much it helps
you to navigate things and make decisions
and parse signal from noise.
So I'd love for you to speak to medical literacy
and how one can become more medically/scientifically
literate.
And certainly, I would highly, highly recommend,
I'll just double down on this, that everybody
read this book because I think that your book
does a good job of this, a very, very good
job.
And I'll just add maybe a sidebar note so
I can hear myself talk a little more.
Which is that there's, I think, a very common
trend among people who are well-educated in
some areas, but not in medicine or science,
to succumb to Scientism with a capital S where
they'll know the term randomized controlled
trial, and they will insist that if you say
anything outside of the purview of that, that
it is unsubstantiated nonsense.
And there are other examples of this.
Or they'll over-index on one thing, as you
mentioned.
So pharmacology, it'll be either good or bad.
But the fact is, anything totally over-indexed,
sort of the Paracelsus "The dose makes the
poison" type of problem.
But could you speak to medical literacy?
Somebody's listening, they say, "You know
what?
I recognize that I don't know much about this.
I would like to go about it in a really effective
way.
How do I do it?"
Dr. Peter Attia: I think you and I have even
talked about this once before, Tim, and I
don't think I had a great answer for you then,
and I don't know that I have a great answer
for you now.
It's really not a simple thing to do.
Let's just start with the nomenclature.
My first day of medical school, I still remember
one of the professors saying — and I don't
remember the numbers, so the story is not
as cool because I don't remember the actual
numbers.
But I'm making the numbers up, but not the
point, okay?
He said, "Well, all of you are smart hotshots
that just graduated the first of your class
in college.
You have an average vocabulary of X words."
And X was like, whatever number.
I honestly don't remember what it was.
Call it 20,000 words.
He said, "In the next two years, i.e., just
in the preclinical phase of medical school,
we are going to add Y words to your vocabulary."
And Y was bigger than X by like 20 percent.
And those were mostly going to be Latin and
Greek words, by the way.
And he was right.
I mean, it was like learning a new language.
So part of it is just the semantic problem.
Now, do you have to know all of that?
Of course not.
But what's proximal?
What's distal?
All of these things kind of factor into this
stuff.
By far the biggest issue, though, and this
is the one that we try to solve the most for
on a weekly basis, there's a reason that we
go to great lengths to write a newsletter
every single Sunday.
It's basically a class.
A lot of times it's like such-and-such a study
is published, and the news picks it up and
writes a take on it that we think is demonstrably
wrong.
Or a paper gets published that gets a lot
of attention that says this, and we think
it's an important paper and we want to highlight
it.
So we try to use those things as case studies,
and I honestly think that's the most efficient
way to go about learning this.
Now, we did write a series six years ago,
I think, called Studying Studies, which is
I think a five-part blog series that Bob Kaplan
and I wrote.
And I think it's probably a great foundation
to just get the basics.
What is a case cohort study?
What is observational epidemiology?
What types of bias exist, and how do you look
for them?
Consider that sort of your basic foundational
knowledge set, but thereafter it becomes reps.
I think Layne Norton also has a course that
he just launched, and I think it's actually
called REPS, but I can't remember what REPS
stands for.
But it's basically a scientific literacy course
in how to read studies about nutrition.
In his case, it's about exercise and nutrition.
Again, we try to cover everything in our newsletter.
We'll talk about a drug study, we'll talk
about a supplement study, an exercise study,
all those sorts of things.
So those to me are the ways you go about doing
this.
You just have to dive into it and a little
bit overcome the fear of it.
I suspect it's not unlike what you would say
if I was asking you, "Tim, I really want to
learn Japanese.
Is there a particular app that I should look
at?"
I think at the end of the day, you'd say,
"Look, man, you've got to learn it.
Here's the way to get the foundational skills,
and then go and find people to speak Japanese
with."
Tim Ferriss: Well, let's actually use that
example.
So learning Japanese.
Because I do think there are parallels here.
I think it comes back to objectives, strategy,
and tactics.
And I just wanted to share a quote that's
one of my favorite quotes that also might
help folks, which is from Ralph Waldo Emerson.
And the quote is, "The man who grasps," this
is, of course, people, but "The man who grasps
principles can successfully select his own
methods.
The man who tries methods, ignoring principles,
is sure to have trouble."
This applies as much in medicine, developing
scientific literacy or learning Japanese.
It applies in all of these places.
And so what I would say, and please feel free
to pick this apart, is that to learn Japanese
is a very broad objective.
So I would encourage someone to refine that
substantially.
And they might refine it to, I would like
to be conversationally fluent, which means
I understand and can convey maybe 80 percent
of what I hear or want to say, in a conversation
that does not include specialist terminology
that is abstract, like economics or art, fill
in the blank.
So you're discussing what happened to whom,
when.
I was born here, I went to school there, I
have two brothers, whatever it might be.
And with that goal, then I would say for the
vast majority of people, if, and this is big
if, they were willing to make it a part-time
job, let's just say with three or four hours
per week spread across four consecutive days.
That if they layered things properly, within
three to six months, if they then added in
a couple of larger sessions for bulk memorization,
and you can use space repetition tools, but
the tools don't matter as much as being really
clear on the objective, that you could become
functionally fluent, conversationally fluent
as I described it, which omits reading and
writing completely in Japanese scripts, probably
within three to six months if you took it
super seriously.
And there are some adjuncts I would add to
that.
So to give people maybe a glimmer of hope
on the medical literacy side, I would say
if people started with your AMA number 30,
this is episode 188, "How to Read and Understand
Scientific Studies."
If people listen to that first, and assume,
folks, before you listen to it that you're
not going to understand at least 30 percent.
Let's just make that an expectation so you
don't get frustrated.
And if they further maybe read some of the
case studies from your newsletter, made that
one of the hours that they spend per week,
just like the Japanese.
If they maybe read a book like Bad Science
by Ben Goldacre, who's an MD.
British, so some of the cultural context and
examples may not resonate for US readers,
but he runs through some of the basics.
And they read Outlive, that making this literacy
your part-time job, a very light part-time
job, for three months is one of the best investments
you'll ever make in your life.
I mean, I really feel like the payoff is so
tremendous that it seems almost crazy to not
learn.
And you don't have to learn a hundred thousand
words, but you need to be familiar with, let's
just call it a few dozen concepts, that you'll
be able to look at databases of studies, or
at least abstracts, not going into all the
supplemental stuff, and make some sense of
A, B, or C.
Are there any suggestions you would have for
just becoming familiar for with what the scientific
method actually entails?
So I could think, read the Wikipedia entry
as a starting point.
But for instance, where a lot of smart people
or seemingly smart people screw up with the
scientific method, is your guess, although
it is a guess, aka the hypothesis, needs to
be falsifiable.
And a lot of people start with completely
impossible-to-falsify guesses.
And it's just you're painting yourself up
shit's creek with without a paddle.
Any suggestions for how people could at least
become familiar with the scientific method
and what that means as far as structured thought
and process?
Dr. Peter Attia: I don't off the top of my
head have a resource that I can point to.
I agree with you that there's so much more
nuance to it than just understanding the caricatured
version that I explained earlier.
For example, how you design an experiment
is essential.
So even if you have a hypothesis that can
be falsified, if you design the wrong experiment
to test it, you can miss out.
This becomes very important, by the way, as
you start to look at studies.
If a study is "negative," how do you know
if it's negative because it was too small
in size and what we would describe as underpowered,
versus it was adequately powered, but there
was no effect.
At the other end of that spectrum, sometimes
a study will find a statistical significance,
but it was overpowered, and that difference,
while statistically significant is clinically
irrelevant.
Now, that kind of stuff we do cover in the
Studying Studies stuff.
But I think what you're describing are these
more important heuristics that truthfully,
maybe there is a great book out there, and
I'm just ignorant of what that book is that
goes through this, but that's the kind of
stuff that I think you learn with practice.
And unfortunately, if you're not doing experiments
— I mean, again, I think I learned most
of this stuff not in medicine, but in the
two years that I spent at the NIH where I
was a fellow, but doing research.
So I was a research fellow, not a clinician.
That's probably where I learned more than
anything about how to do science.
And so I think anybody who's been in a lab
is just learning that.
But it's very informal.
At least for me, it wasn't a structured thing.
Tim Ferriss: But in terms of priorities, I
would say, folks, man, I've seen so many people
lost in the medical system, especially when
they suddenly have a serious diagnosis with
some form of cancer or otherwise.
And they are absolutely helpless because they
do not have a handful of concepts that they've
become comfortable with and just a basic set
of terminology.
So at the very least, look up Sir Francis
Bacon.
I'm sure there's a biography, an excellent
biography out there somewhere.
And it will no doubt track the development
of the, I guess, Baconian approach.
Dr. Peter Attia: One thing I'll add to this,
Tim, before we leave this topic, is also for
folks to look up Austin Bradford Hill.
So Austin Bradford Hill, scientist of the
middle part of the 20th century.
To him, we owe the Bradford Hill criteria.
So there are, I believe, nine Bradford Hill
criteria, which are the criteria that we use
to scrutinize observational data.
So when you have epidemiologic data, how can
you scrutinize them to understand and change
your confidence in the likelihood that these
data are causal?
I mean, causality is one of the most important
concepts in science.
Tim Ferriss: Could you also just define observational
study versus randomized control trial so that
people have that?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
So an observational study, it doesn't have
an intervention.
So you can observe things, either looking
backwards, so things that already happened,
you can go back and look at what happened.
You can even observe things prospectively,
but without intervening.
So saying, hey, we noticed that there are
a group of redheads over here and there are
a group of brunettes over here, and we're
just going to follow them for the next 10
years and see if the color of their hair predicts
their life satisfaction, making this up, of
course.
And so you might get an answer from that and
say, oh, my God, the people with red hair
were so much more likely to get melanoma.
I mean, this is devastating, and it must be
that something about red hair is causing skin
cancer.
And it must be that brown hair must be reflecting
the sun and those people aren't getting skin
cancer.
So there's a correlation.
So another question is, do we know if there's
a cause there?
Do we know if the red hair is causing those
people to get more skin cancer than the people
with brown hair?
And the answer is probably not, right?
The answer is probably that red hair is associated
with fairer skin and that that's the issue.
Because if you really wanted to know if red
hair was causal, you would randomize people
to different groups and you would actually
dye the hair in one group one color, and dye
the hair in the other group another color,
and then you would follow them.
You see?
So what Bradford Hill's criteria allow us
to do is look at nine factors, such as the
strength of the observation.
So what's the actual magnitude of the observation?
What's the reproducibility of it?
What's the biological plausibility of it?
Is there an analogy to it?
Is there a dose effect to it?
And as you go through these nine criteria,
which I think I actually do this a couple
of times in the book, because so much of the
data we look at around nutrition and exercise
are unfortunately epidemiological.
We can't do the controlled experiments.
But it's what allows us to say, when I read
a study that says 12 hazelnuts will reduce
your risk of death, 12 hazelnuts a day in
consumption reduces risk of death by 10 percent,
I can look at that and say, total nonsense.
That's just epidemiologic nonsense.
Conversely, when I look at epidemiologic data
that say, people who are really, really strong
live longer than people who are really, really
weak, by going through those nine criteria,
I can be much more confident that that is
actually causal.
Tim Ferriss: I'll mention two things.
The first is if you're going to get — because
we're mentioning a number of different books,
and this is not just to blows smoke up Peter's
ass, which by the way was a real thing.
I found a menu from the wild west, and it
was all these various things you could have
done to you, and blowing smoke up your ass
was like $50.
It was the most expensive.
So that's a real thing.
So it's not just that I'm doing that, but
if you're going to buy one book on this stuff,
get Outlive because it covers a broad spectrum.
And I want to also mention, because I think
this is really critical, and we'll probably
come back to this, but it isn't just about
extending lifespan, but extending healthspan
and having full optionality physically, or
trying to preserve that to the greatest extent
possible for the longest period of time possible.
I will add, though, that people will see,
for instance, and a lot of this medical or
scientific literacy is so you don't get fooled
by misinterpretation or sensationalism in
media.
Because you'll see a headline that's something
like "Bananas increase your risk of colorectal
cancer by a hundred percent."
And what that means, though, if you dig into
the data is like, all right, your risk goes
from one in five billion to two in five billion.
So it's just like, from a behavioral standpoint,
it just does not matter at all.
There's a book called How to Lie With Statistics
by Darrell Huff, which I think is a very fast
read.
And that will also complement everything that
we're talking about.
So let's look a little more closely at some
of the content and interventions and tools
in the book.
And I'm not sure this is a great way to kick
it off, but there's an expression I've heard
at least applied to medicine quite a few times,
which is 50 percent of what we know is wrong,
we just don't know which 50 percent.
And so I'm curious to know what you have seen,
peeking behind the veil at what is not working,
and what you have then designed to address
that misfire, in your practice and by extension
in the book.
You mentioned a few things, like apoB levels.
You mentioned being very specific with exercise
prescription, being extremely specific, and
the possibility of lowering certain types
of risks fourfold.
So I'll let you tackle that however you want.
We can start wherever makes sense.
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, I mean, we could probably
talk about different things within different
buckets.
So starting with sleep, I think that with
sleep, I like to simplify things a little
bit sometimes.
So one thing that I think is happening a lot
right now is people are getting, probably
at least some people overly anxious about
what their sleep trackers are telling them.
So we've got a problem where the pendulum
has swung a little too far to the other side,
where maybe 10 years ago, nobody thought at
all about sleep.
Now you've got a class of people, me among
them, who maybe think too much about sleep.
All of a sudden, it becomes a little bit counterproductive.
We see this in a subset of our patients.
The first and most important prescription
for those people is stop tracking.
Take the tracker off.
Let's just focus on the fundamentals.
What time are you getting into bed, and what
time are you getting out of bed?
If we can, within 15 to 30 minutes on either
one of those, completely fix that and completely
toggle on the basic blocking and tackling
aspects of sleep hygiene, which have to do
with food, alcohol, light, temperature, noise,
et cetera, I mean, you're going to be okay.
I don't really need to know what your sleep
score is and how many minutes of this sleep
versus that sleep you had.
I personally go through this myself.
I'll go through phases of time where I'm not
looking at any sleep-tracking device.
If I know I'm going to be in an environment
where sleep is compromised, which is basically
a lot of the time if I'm traveling, I don't
even take a sleep tracker with me because
why do I need something to remind me of what's
probably happening?
How about I just do the best job I can and
be a little less data focused?
That's an example of where I feel like, a
couple years ago, I would've just said, "More
data is always the answer."
Now I think I'm a bit more measured, and I
say, "Look, sometimes more data is not always
the answer."
Now, the flip side of that is there's nothing
that will demonstrate to a person how much
late night food and alcohol are ruining their
sleep than a sleep tracker.
I do think it's really valuable to see that.
For many of my patients, that has been the
most decisive thing that has reduced their
alcohol intake.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, for sure.
Yes.
Dr. Peter Attia: Despite what a lot of the
epidemiology will tell people, alcohol is
not good for you in any dose.
It doesn't mean we shouldn't drink it at all,
but let's not delude ourselves into thinking
it's actually healthy at some low dose.
It's not.
Understanding that it's a toxin can, I think,
help you have a more measured response.
My response to alcohol, while we're on that
topic, is if I drink something that doesn't
taste incredible, I pour it out.
I'm never going to tolerate a bad glass of
wine, ever.
It's just not worth it.
Tim Ferriss: Since we're on it, well, I'm
going to pull us back to this question of
data, probably through the lens of continuous
glucose monitors and the best uses and maybe
the most common misuses for people who do
not have type two or type one diabetes.
But let's just sit with the alcohol for a
second.
What are your personal rules for alcohol consumption,
outside of if it tastes mediocre or shitty,
it gets poured out, which is a great rule,
but what are your favorite types of alcohol?
How do you personally navigate that?
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, I'll start with quantity.
Yeah.
I would personally just say there's got to
be an insane reason to have more than two
drinks in a day.
It's somewhere between zero and two.
And it's got to be a really good reason to
drink on more than three days a week.
In the back of my mind, I'm keeping a tally,
which is I really shouldn't be having more
than about seven drinks in a week.
Again, seven drinks in one day is very different
than one drink a day for seven days.
It's the frequency and dose that defines the
poison.
The second thing is I really have to make
sure that drinking is a good three hours away
from sleep.
Again, when I say these things, people say,
"Peter, you must be a robot."
No, I'm just saying these are general principles.
There are going to be times when I violate
that.
I think I posted something on Instagram a
little while ago, which was the most rancid
night of sleep, when my sleep data were comically
bad.
The reason was we had friends over.
It was very late.
We drank.
We ate.
I basically went to bed.
By the time they left at 10:30, I went to
bed, and we had just finished eating.
Not surprisingly, my sleep sucked.
The point I made in the post was I'd do it
again.
It was a fantastic night with our friends.
The four of us hadn't had dinner together
in a long time.
You just have to be very thoughtful and deliberate
about the choices and trade-offs that you
make.
As far as the type of alcohol, this is, again,
an example of something I think we tend to
over-index to.
It's "I drink a lot, but let me tell you,
it's just vodka and tequila.
It's got to be good for me, right?"
It's like, "No.
Alcohol's alcohol."
I love tequila.
I love mezcal.
I love really good wine.
I love really dark Belgian beer.
I'm not deluded to think that any of those
are healthy.
I know that there are some people who have
a horrible reaction to certain types of alcohol.
Well, I would put that in the same category
as people who have a horrible reaction to
certain types of foods.
Don't consume them.
I think mostly where I focus, Tim, is on how
much am I going to drink, how close is it
going to be to bed, and what's the total tally
per week, and never exceed a certain tally
in a given day.
Tim Ferriss: I was waiting for the right time
to bring this up, Peter I know that people
say cookies are bad for you, but I've only
been eating Nutter Butters.
I'm kidding.
I feel like that's the equivalent although
it's less of a neurotoxin.
Let's hop to continuous —
Dr. Peter Attia: I do love Nutter Butters,
by the way.
Tim Ferriss: They are good.
They're so good.
Dr. Peter Attia: I don't know the last time
I had one, but oh, my God, now that you reminded
me of that.
That's horrible of you to do that.
Tim Ferriss: Well, that'll combine nicely
with all the GBs and the CGMs.
Inside joke.
Could you speak to continuous glucose monitors?
For a long time, I mean, even still now, these
are broadly thought of as something that one
might only use if they have some form of diabetes.
However, there are people who do not fit in
those categories who use them.
I would love for you to just perhaps give
us a bit of an overview on CGMs and what you
have seen as the best uses and how you use
them in your practice.
Dr. Peter Attia: A continuous glucose monitor
is a device.
There are really two big ones on the market
right now.
One is made by a company called Dexcom, and
one is made by a company called Abbott.
The latter is called the Freestyle Libre.
I think it's a company that Abbott acquired
many years ago.
These are devices that are worn usually on
the tricep.
They can also be on the abdomen.
They have a little, tiny filament that is
quickly shot in with a needle into the subcutaneous
space.
The filament remains after the needle comes
out, and the filament sits in a part of the
body where it can sample something called
interstitial fluid.
This is basically the fluid between cells.
To be clear, it's not sampling the blood.
It samples the interstitial fluid, and it
measures glucose level there.
It's basically calibrated to know, based on
what the reading is there, what the glucose
level is in the blood.
A continuous glucose monitor, as its name
suggests, is a way to give you real-time information
about what your blood glucose is.
As you said, for people with type one diabetes,
which was the first use case, it was a very
important innovation because people with type
one diabetes are by definition dependent on
insulin.
They are using insulin exogenously to do the
job of their pancreas, which is no longer
working.
The pancreas, of course, is this brilliant
organ, where it's the one that's auto regulating
glucose and insulin, or glucose via insulin.
When that goes away, they have to be the one
to do it.
So now they have this device that is at least
giving them real-time glucose information,
and they can adjust insulin injections as
needed.
It obviously didn't take long for that to
expand into a much, much larger market, i.e.,
10 times the size, which is people with type
two diabetes, some of whom do require exogenous
insulin, some of whom do not, but all of whom
by definition have a carbohydrate and glucose
tolerance disorder.
The very definition of type two diabetes is
based around unregulated peripheral glucose.
This tool is therefore helpful.
It's helpful in, first and foremost, I think,
knowing what to eat.
I think, historically, we have given people
with type two diabetes abjectly horrible news
and insight with regard to what to eat.
I mean, we just haven't really helped them
think through this problem.
The CGM makes it pretty clear that not all
foods are created equal when it comes to managing
glucose homeostasis.
Everything I've said so far is relatively
straightforward.
This is a great example, by the way, of Medicine
3.0 versus Medicine 2.0.
Everything I've said so far more or less makes
sense if you're in Medicine 2.0.
In fact, I think we're finally at the point
where even Medicine 2.0 is starting to accept
the fact that carbohydrate restriction is
a really good idea for people with type two
diabetes.
It's not the only way, by the way.
Caloric restriction in general will work to
improve insulin sensitivity, which therefore
improves glucose regulation.
But it does seem that carbohydrate restriction,
as a form or a gateway to caloric restriction,
has greater efficacy than other methods.
Once we now talk about people without diabetes,
Medicine 2.0 would argue a CGM plays no role.
Okay.
Is there a randomized control trial demonstrating
the efficacy of CGM in anything outside of
patients with diabetes?
There is not.
But now we have to get into the leap of faith
that one takes when you start triangulating
between other pieces of data.
We want to start with one, which is, in a
population of non-diabetics, is there any
evidence that glucose levels matter?
Type two diabetes is defined as having a hemoglobin
A1C above 6.5 percent.
Hemoglobin A1C is just a way to measure how
much glucose is stuck to hemoglobin.
By knowing what that number is, you can impute
what the average blood glucose is in that
individual over the preceding three months.
So 6.5, which is the cutoff, translates to
an average blood glucose of 140 milligrams
per deciliter.
The question, then, would be if you take two
people who don't have diabetes, one of whom
has a hemoglobin A1C of 5.0, and one of whom
has a hemoglobin A1C of 6.0, neither of them
are diabetic, is there any difference in their
outcomes?
To put that in perspective, the guy at 5.0
has an average blood glucose of about 100
milligrams per deciliter.
The person at 6.0 has an average blood glucose
of about 130 milligrams per deciliter.
Pardon me.
120 milligrams per deciliter.
They're both outside that diabetes range.
Well, the answer here is actually pretty clear.
It is that there is a difference.
In fact, for a non-diabetic population, the
lower the average blood glucose, as estimated
by hemoglobin a1c, the lower the all-cause
mortality.
What's the implication now?
Well, if the implication is, if you take a
group of people who don't have diabetes but
want to live longer, i.e., they want to lower
their risk of cancer, they want to lower their
risk of cardiovascular disease, they want
to lower their risk of neurodegenerative disease,
I think we can make a pretty reasonable leap
of faith that having a lower average blood
glucose is better than having a higher average
blood glucose, even if that higher average
does not put you in the range of a diabetic.
So now the question becomes, are there tools
to help us manage that?
One tool would just be the A1C.
You could say, "Well, I'm just going to get
my hemoglobin A1C measured every six months."
The problem with that, as we know, is that
hemoglobin A1C is very easy to mislead.
It's very dependent on red blood cell turnover.
The more rapidly red blood cells turnover,
the more artificially low the hemoglobin A1C
will be.
Conversely, the longer the red blood cell
sticks around, the higher, artificially, the
hemoglobin A1C will be.
It's for that reason that we like to use CGM
to actually get true measurements of average
blood glucose.
When a patient who doesn't have diabetes puts
on a CGM for the first time, they're invariably
surprised.
There's this real learning phase that comes.
You've done this, Tim.
I know you were doing this.
Probably 10 years ago, you wore your first
one.
Everybody goes through this.
I remember for me, it's been about eight years
since I started.
At first, you simply cannot believe the things
that drive your blood glucose up.
It's so simple —
Tim Ferriss: Can you give some examples?
Dr. Peter Attia: — it sounds dumb.
Yeah.
I remember the first time I had Raisinets.
It's not like I didn't expect it to go up.
I didn't expect it to go up like that.
Exercise.
Certain forms of exercise.
By the way, I'm not saying this is pathologic.
There's nothing wrong when you're exercising
for your glucose to skyrocket if you're doing
tabatas or you're doing HIIT workouts.
Again, it's not pathological, but it's super
interesting.
Other things that I think are pathological
is how much your blood glucose goes up if
you had a poor night of sleep.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for sure.
Dr. Peter Attia: If you have a horrible night
of sleep, your insulin sensitivity gets crushed
the next day, and your glucose levels go up.
Well, that's actually very interesting.
Again, maybe you could argue that adds too
much stress to the fire, but it's an insight,
nevertheless, that can help drive a behavior
change.
I think in the book, I cover my 10 best insights
from years of CGM in myself and patients.
It's about different foods.
Foods high in fiber are going to have one
effect.
Lean sources of protein versus fatty sources
of protein, all those sorts of things.
Ultimately, I think CGM becomes a really helpful
tool for compliance.
It becomes a behavioral tool.
We tend to gamify it a little bit.
I know that when I'm wearing CGM, which, I
just happen to be right now, by the way, I'm
going to think twice before eating something
stupid.
Again, it's purely just because my personality
likes to gamify things.
It's like, "Yeah, I'm tempted to go and eat
all the leftover waffles on my kid's plate,
but I just know."
It's like, "Eh, it's going to shoot my blood
glucose up, and I like not doing that.
Where I think people get into trouble and
where the counter-argument is, which is a
fair argument, is, look, if you only index
on blood glucose, you could still end up doing
a bunch of things that aren't healthy.
If you ate bacon for every meal every day,
your blood glucose would not go that high,
but it's probably not the healthiest choice.
I would agree with that.
But by that logic, we shouldn't look at body
weight, either, because by smoking cigarettes,
your body weight will go down.
Does that mean body weight is a lousy measurement?
No.
It just means that any measurement in isolation
can be ridiculous and can be gamed.
We shouldn't ignore blood glucose any more
than we should ignore body weight or body
fat or body composition.
We just have to understand that it's one of
many tools that we can look at.
The CGM, again, do I think this is necessary
to live a longer, healthier life?
Of course not.
It's simply one tool that we have to help
us understand how to regulate one of the four
macronutrients.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to just add two things
to that.
The first is people listening who have not
experienced a CGM may hear puncture filaments
and imagine something out of Hostel 2 or something
like that.
I will say that 2008 was the first time I
used a Dexcom, which was the size of the cell
phone used by —
Dr. Peter Attia: It's like a baseball.
Tim Ferriss: — Gordon Gekko in Wall Street.
It was huge.
The experience of putting what felt like,
to me, subjectively barbecue tongs into my
abdomen was very unpleasant at the time.
I have, however, tried the latest generations,
and you basically feel nothing.
I mean, it's so easy in my experience.
I don't know how many of your patients report
a lot of pain with that, but I was shocked
by how completely innocuous the whole procedure
was.
It was very, very mild, very quick, very easy.
So I just wanted to mention that.
Secondly, this probably applies more to your
patients than to you, but in the book, you
mentioned the Hawthorne effect, which I think
was first coined in manufacturing, and looking
at worker effectiveness or output.
That is the phenomenon whereby people modify
their behavior when they're being watched.
I think that is another selling point for
some form of accountability.
Is there anything you'd like to add to that?
Dr. Peter Attia: No.
I mean, I think there are some patients of
ours who actually want to utilize the Hawthorne
effect.
If we agree mutually to do so, we can see
all their data.
They can just say, "Look, I want you to be
looking at my CGM data every day.
You're an accountability partner for me, so
I'm going to eat less junk food."
Tim Ferriss: What are some of the other perhaps
under-emphasized or underutilized metrics
that you think are important?
This could be in the realm of metrics or tools.
It could be forms of screening.
It could be blood markers of different types.
There are a few that come to mind that I imagine
are on this list.
It could be physical performance markers of
some type.
What are some that come to mind?
Dr. Peter Attia: If we're going to just talk
in magnitude, VO2 max and muscular strength
stand in a league of their own.
There's really nothing that's within the ZIP
code of those two metrics.
Having very, very high VO2 max for your age
and sex, and being very strong, I mean, again,
they have more of a positive impact than any
single thing we can think of has a negative
impact.
That includes having end-stage renal disease,
being on the wait list for a kidney while
you get dialysis, being a smoker, having high
blood pressure, having type two diabetes,
being obese.
The downside of those things is relatively
small compared to the upside of having a high
VO2 max and being very strong.
We almost shouldn't even talk about things
until people are willing to accept that fact
and take the steps necessary to address them.
Now, you might say, "Well, how many people
can become very, very strong or have a very
high VO2 max?"
The answer is I don't know.
I don't know, especially on the VO2 max side.
To get into that top 2.5 percent of the population
where you really start to see an enormous
gap between you and everybody else in terms
of lifespan, yeah, maybe only a quarter of
the population has the potential to get there.
But the point is everybody has the potential
to be more fit than they are, outside of people
who are already doing everything they can.
So just going from being in the bottom 25
percent of the population to the 25th to 50th
percentile of the population cuts your risk
of all-cause mortality in half at any point
in time.
There's nothing that compares to that.
There's no drug out there that's going to
do that.
Again, I think we could talk about drugs all
day long and how I think they're really important
and how we could think about controlling apoB
and rapamycin and metformin, all these other
things.
All that stuff is pixie dust compared to what
these things are.
On the strength side, the same thing.
I mean, anyone who's got older parents knows
this.
If you really want to watch somebody suffer
when they're aging, you watch them losing
their cognition, and you watch them losing
their physical body.
You watch them lose the ability to move around
with ease, to have balance, to be pain free,
all of these things.
Well, a big part of that is being strong.
Strength is something we can actually hang
onto as we age.
We lose quickness long before we lose strength.
That's the good news.
The bad news is you have to be very deliberate
in how you train it.
I'm sure on the podcast, you've discussed
type one and type two muscle fibers.
People are probably familiar with that.
Tim Ferriss: Well, why don't you reiterate
that?
Dr. Peter Attia: Our muscles are made up of
these fibers.
They're very unique properties.
Muscles are these multicellular things where
the cells are these long fibers that contract
past each other.
That's what creates the contraction of a muscle.
But if you dig a little bit deeper, you have
different types of fibers.
You have type one fibers, which are fueled
mostly, if not entirely, by an aerobic process.
They can use fat.
They can use glucose, but they do so in the
presence of oxygen primarily.
They're very slow to fatigue, which is mostly
where the name comes from, but they don't
generate that much force.
These are the muscle fibers that are mostly
on display when you're walking or just carrying
out activities of daily living.
You can go for a walk for —
Tim Ferriss: Commonly called slow twitch,
as you alluded to.
Slow twitch muscle fibers.
Dr. Peter Attia: Correct.
Yeah.
You can do things for a long period of time,
and these things don't fatigue.
Conversely, another subset of these fibers
are type two fibers.
They're called fast twitch muscle fibers.
They're fast to fatigue.
Now, they're much more powerful.
When a type two fiber contracts, far more
is happening.
It's generating far more force, but it's doing
so with a different metabolic strategy.
It's glycolytic.
It's just using glucose, broken down glycogen,
and it's going to fatigue quickly.
It's accumulating metabolic byproducts that
are leading to fatigue.
There's a reason why, if I say, "Tim, jump
up and down as high as you can, as many times
as you can," this is not going to be a long
exercise.
We don't have to sit and wait two hours for
you to finish that.
You're going to fatigue pretty quickly if
you're doing maximal jumps.
Whereas, if I say, "Jump rope," you could
do that for 30 minutes easily if you're relatively
fit person.
So you get the sense of the difference.
Now, as we age, we lose power and explosiveness
more than anything else.
We lose that the soonest.
That's due to the atrophy of the type two
fiber.
Again, this comes back down to strategy.
That's why, if you want to live a longer,
better life, you have to have a strategy in
place for maintaining type two fibers.
You're not going to get that without resistance.
You can't say, "Look, I play tennis every
day.
I walk every day."
Those things are great.
They're not doing something for your type
two fibers.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Let me hop in for a second.
I want to get specific on that because I think
some of the approaches or tools might be counterintuitive
for folks.
First, just some random trivia for folks who
might be interested.
If you've ever carved a chicken or a turkey,
neither of those like to fly very much.
The breast meat tends to be white, and then
you have the dark meat.
Well, there you have type two, type one fibers
respectively.
So just for the next time you're cutting up
the bird.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
The reason the legs are dark is they have
much more mitochondria.
Those are their slow twitch muscles there
that are heavily dependent on oxygen delivery
and oxidative phosphorylation.
Whereas, the white meat, the breast meat is
very fast twitch.
Quick, quick, quick flapping.
Doesn't have the mitochondria, has far less
of it, and therefore that's a less oxygen
rich muscle.
Tim Ferriss: I think the quick, quick flap
—
Dr. Peter Attia: We, of course, look — yeah,
we look all red.
Tim Ferriss: Go ahead.
Go ahead.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
When you dissect us, of course, you don't
see that difference.
Our type one and type two fibers are less
clearly separated.
Tim Ferriss: If someone wants to improve strength,
correct me if I'm wrong, but you have a number
of — maybe they're not just heuristics.
I mean, they're direct indicators, but you
have a number of things that you focus on.
I'm sure there are many others.
But in the strength category, I would love
to know how you define very strong.
Perhaps this would be a place to talk about,
or at least include, hand strength, farmer's
carry, or anything else that you'd like to
add that might not immediately show up on
someone's mental radar when they're thinking
of strength.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
I mean, there are a handful of strength categories
that we think really matter and just ideas
that are important when you think about strength.
One of them is the importance of understanding
eccentric versus concentric strength and how
both are very important.
I actually put something up on Instagram the
other day about this, where I just explained
that the concentric phase is basically the
go and the eccentric phase is the slow.
You accelerate through concentric force, which
is the force a muscle generates as it is shortening.
That moves you forward.
The eccentric phase, which is equally important
but oft ignored, is the strength or the force
that a muscle is exhibiting as it is lengthening.
That's what's decelerating.
That's what's slowing you down.
Andy Galpin, I think, recently talked about
a great metric, and I agree, this is a fantastic
metric.
I'll check mine constantly.
How far a broad jump can you do?
I want to make sure that I can do a standing
broad jump that's higher than my height laying
down.
If I'm five foot 10, I want to make sure I'm
jumping at least six feet on a broad jump.
A broad jump's a really interesting test.
It's a profoundly extreme example of concentric
and eccentric strength in the same movement.
If you're just standing there and you want
to jump six feet in front of you, that requires
an enormous explosion.
That's a very high concentric load.
But guess what?
If you want to not break your nose when you
land and destroy your knees, you better be
able to decelerate and slow yourself down.
That's an unbelievable eccentric ask.
While that's a very extreme example, consider
walking up and down stairs.
Walking up the stairs is very taxing concentrically.
But where do most people get hurt in life?
It's actually walking downstairs.
If you watch, especially as people age, the
difficulty they have in slowing themselves
down when they're coming downstairs or taking
a step off a curb, this is where people are
falling and breaking their hips.
It's far less that they're falling due to
concentric weakness and far more that they're
falling due to eccentric weakness.
Therefore, principle number one in our strength
training is always be doing both, not necessarily
in the same movement, not necessarily focusing
equally on a given day, but everything we
want to do, we want to make sure that we are
hitting the concentric and the eccentric phase,
not just the more obvious, which is the concentric.
Tim Ferriss: Now, does that take the form
of simply accentuating the lowering in the
case of, say, a trap bar deadlift or something
like that, where you have something like two
seconds up, four seconds down?
Or does it take other —
Dr. Peter Attia: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: — specific forms?
Dr. Peter Attia: Exactly.
I mean, there are other ways.
They're a very specific exercise that you'll
do.
For example, a Nordic rollout, a Nordic fall
for a hamstring exercise where you're — you
know what I'm talking about.
When you're kneeling on a mat and your feet
are held in position and you sort of allow
yourself to slowly come down?
That's just purely eccentric.
Tim Ferriss: Requires quite a bit of starting
strength to do.
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, truthfully, we wouldn't
have people do that out of the gate.
You'll do that with assistance to start, because
most people simply don't have the hamstring
strength to do that.
Yes.
It can be accomplished greatly by using slow,
what we call negatives.
So focusing just as much on the negative is
the positive.
So for example, one of my favorite exercises
to do are step-ups because one, it's a single
leg exercise, it's a beautiful hip hinge.
We can talk about it in some detail in a moment
because hip hinging is another one of the
big principles and it allows you to do a very
nice isolation of the eccentric on the step-down.
You really have to be able to control that.
If you can't control it, you're using too
much resistance, obviously.
So hip hinging is another big important principle.
Again, hip hinging, when people think about
that, they think, does that have to be a squat
or a deadlift?
No, it doesn't have to be.
It can be a hip thruster, it can be a lunge,
it can be a step-up.
I think the step-up might be the single most
important one for people to do because it
doesn't have any axial loading.
Tim Ferriss: Can you explain what you mean
by that?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
When you're doing something like a squat or
a deadlift, there's weight that is basically
pulling your spine down to your hips.
The squat, it's because the weight is actually
sitting there and the deadlift, it's because
the weight is being — the force is being
transferred through your arms there.
But in either case, you are loading the axis
of your spine and that's fine if you know
how to do it safely.
But as you know, having done these things,
that's not just something you can walk in
off the street and do.
You really have to be coached how to do that
stuff safely.
Stepping up onto a block is something that's
much safer to do.
It's also something that you can do with a
single leg at a time, and therefore you get
to see what your asymmetries are because we
all have them.
I am so deep down the rabbit hole of step-ups
that I can't even explain the nuances in oblique
compression, pelvic angles in the difference
between when my left and right leg do it.
But tinkering with that stuff allows me to
work out so many kinks with how my body works.
You mentioned another one earlier, which is
being able to carry heavy things.
This is just such an essential skill for our
species.
It's something that we do better than anything.
There is no animal that can carry with their
hands what we can do.
Certainly a strong male, but certainly even
a strong female can carry their body weight
in their hands.
Half their body weight in each hand is not
an insurmountable ask for us.
So carrying got so much —
Tim Ferriss: Would that be a hypothetical
target for your patients?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, we would like to see
our patients carry half their body weight
in each hand for a minute.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: For a minute?
Dr. Peter Attia: So walk around with half
your body weight in each hand for a minute
and having strong hands, it's one of the most
correlated findings with longevity.
So we talked earlier about what does it mean
to be really, really strong?
Well, unfortunately, the data on this are
based on what the studies show and the studies
are testing interesting things, but they're
not exhaustive.
So they're usually looking at grip strength,
leg extension, bench press are the most commonly
tested things, but grip strength comes up
over and over and over again in studies as
such a proxy for longevity, lower risk.
I think there's a figure in my book that talks
about the unbelievable monotonic decline in
both the risk of onset of dementia and death
from dementia as grip strength increases.
Again, you just kind of go back to the Bradford
Hill criteria and you look at the strength
of the associations, you look at the consistency
of these associations, you look at the dose
effect of these associations.
Very hard for me to believe that there isn't
causal relationships here.
That being stronger training to be stronger
will actually improve outcomes.
Not just that strength is a marker of health,
which is obviously correlated with living
longer, if that makes sense.
I mean there's a distinction there, so.
Yeah, we think that carrying things is very
important and yeah, I'll go through different
phases.
As you know, I love rucking.
So that's another thing that I think is just
a great all round way to now combine two different
types of exercise, something that's part of
strength and something that's part of endurance.
Also, rucking gives you — so just for people
who don't know, rucking is just basically
carrying a really heavy weighted backpack.
Probably one of the most important tools used
in the training of special forces in the military.
We have so many friends that have been through
that and I'm amazed at how much they rucked.
It's like eight hours a day.
They're just walking around with 75 pounds
on their back if not more.
Tim Ferriss: What does your protocol methodology
look like for rucking?
Dr. Peter Attia: So I use 55 to 60 pounds,
and I'll typically do an hour ruck because
of where I live.
It's really hilly, so I really like that.
But going up the hills, I'm going hard.
I'm really pushing my cardio up the hills
and I'm trying to find the steepest hills
possible to come down because that's working
that huge eccentric, that gear, it's really
forcing me to be able to decelerate on the
way down those hills with a lot of weight.
You're not getting the pounding.
I think that's the beauty of —
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Dr. Peter Attia: You're not pounding your
knee with the impact you would if you had
to run to produce that effect.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's probably the most
compelling reason that I started rucking a
few years ago, especially in preparation for
certain alpine hunts and so on, did a ton
of rucking and the collateral benefits, they're
not really collateral.
The direct benefits were this sort of holy
shit effect that sometimes I've seen with
kettlebell swings and other things where this
translation that you wouldn't expect pops
up in all sorts of ways.
I used to be a runner, but I ended up — you
probably didn't know this, but I used to be
a cross country runner when I was, say, up
to about age 15.
Then through poor choices, like doing lots
of wrestling and other impact sports, developed
knee issues and so stopped running.
But I always missed the sensation of getting
a good workout while walking or moving in
some fashion on ground.
Rucking solved that.
So coming back to VO2 max, so VO2 max, I've
always wondered to what degree someone can
improve VO2 max, you already spoke to the
benefits, even if you're moving from say,
25th percentile, the 50th percentile, huge
benefit, right?
I mean half I think you said halving, halfing
cutting in half certain mortality risks.
What have you found to be the best approaches
for improving VO2 max?
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, first off, it can actually
be improved quite a bit.
I think the research out there understates
how much it can be approved because the research
studies are relatively short.
So it's true that in a 12-week study, you
might see an eight percent improvement or
a 10 percent improvement.
I would say that's just the tip of the iceberg,
we're not talking about 12 weeks of training
here.
We're talking about a lifetime of training
and we're talking about 25-50 percent improvement
in VO2 max that anybody who's been involved
in serious training will see all day long.
So the, how is also very important, the analogy
I like to use, which I'm borrowing from one
of my old cycling coaches, is that think about
building a pyramid.
The VO2 max is the height of the pyramid.
So if you want to build a really high pyramid,
it also has to have a really wide base.
So the key for building a high VO2 max is
saying, "I'm going to spend about 80 percent
of my aerobic training time in zone two."
This is counterintuitive.
A lot of people think, "Oh, my god.
If I want to build a high VO2 max, it has
to be all intense training."
No, you have to first and foremost build that
huge aerobic base.
That is the pyramid.
Tim Ferriss: That foundation.
Dr. Peter Attia: That allows you to make the
peak higher.
So once you have that aerobic base, that other
20 percent of the time is used well above.
So basically most people are training too
hard to build the base, but not hard enough
to build the peak.
So I kind of think of as garbage training
zone and not to rip on —
Tim Ferriss: Not to get too technical.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
But that's sort of the problem with doing
a lot of fun classes and stuff.
Look, it's absolutely better than sitting
on the couch for sure, but it's not specific
enough to achieve this goal.
So you really want to separate that zone two
from that zone five.
When it comes to VO2 max, you basically have
to be in the three- to eight-minute range
is the sweet spot.
So it's got to be intervals that are about
three to eight minutes.
So three minutes at the low end, meaning you're
doing something that is so hard, you can only
do it for about three minutes and at the high
end, eight minutes.
So if you can do it for more than eight minutes,
it's not doing a lot for your VO2 max.
If you can't do it for three minutes, it's
also not doing the maximum amount for your
VO2 max.
Tim Ferriss: Just for clarity, that's the
zone five that you're referring to, building
the peak?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Here you're typically doing about a one-to-one
work to rest recovery.
That's how hard these intervals are.
So if you do three minutes at that, whatever
that output is, you're going to need about
three minutes of recovery before you can do
it again.
So we typically say, "Look, a good starting
point is four by four," four on four off four
times.
That's just a great workout to start just
doing that workout once a week.
So let's say three days a week you're going
to do your cardio and it's going to be kind
of the low-end zone two cardio.
One day a week, you pick an exertion level
that you can barely get through four minutes
of it, you can do it, but you've a little
bit left in the tank, but not much.
That you need four minutes to recover.
Then you do that four times.
Sandwich between a warmup and a cool down.
Tim Ferriss: If I'm understanding correctly,
that would be the building of the peak.
What does the zone two training look like?
Dr. Peter Attia: Long and slow.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Aside from subjective perceived
exertion, is there a heart rate range or anything
else that you can use as sort of a proxy indicator?
So people can have something to aim for?
Dr. Peter Attia: Once you get fit enough,
lactate becomes really good.
So measuring lactate with a point of care
like a finger prick device is what I do.
You're looking for a lactate level of about
1.7 to two millimole for most people is the
zone.
For people who aren't yet fit enough, their
lactates are usually going to be way higher
than that while they're still training that
energy system.
Or if people just don't want to do that.
For those people RPE, rate of perceived exertion,
is really the best way to do it and it's far
more accurate than heart rate.
So the RPE is you should be able to talk,
but you don't want to.
So today I did a zone two ride.
I spent the entire — this is very unusual,
but just because of the way it was today,
I spent the entire zone two on a phone call.
My entire workout was on a phone call.
There was absolutely no confusion on the guy
on the other end of that line that I was on
my bike and that I wanted him to talk more
than me, like I was breathing like this.
He was like, okay.
So yeah, I mean, that's kind of how I was
going at it.
I can nasally breathe when I'm doing zone
two, but I'm right at the limits of what I
can do.
It's very easy for me to nasally breathe.
I don't mouth breathe at night or anything
like that.
So that kind of gives you a sense of it.
If you can talk pretty easily while you're
doing it.
If you're out on a walk and you're talking
to somebody, that's too easy.
If you can't talk at all, that's too hard.
I think that, by far the best test.
Tim Ferriss: Just to give people some more
specifics.
So for the zone two, how long would a target
session be?
How many times per week?
Then similarly for the four-by-four, let's
just say that you described for the zone five
building the peak, how many times per week
would you do that?
Dr. Peter Attia: I think if we can do that
once a week is great.
Tim Ferriss: That's zone five?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, zone five.
I think for zone two, we think minimum effective
dose.
So again, it depends on where you're starting.
If you're starting with you've never exercised
in your life, I mean, boy, we'd be happy to
get you doing two 30-minute a week zone two
sessions, but you very quickly will start
to adapt to that.
Then I think we start to get into three hours
being the MED.
That might be three 60-minute sessions or
four 45-minute sessions.
Tim Ferriss: Have you ever tried, Peter, and
I'm just going to bring this up because we've
spent a good amount of time together, and
this has been a bit of a revelation for me.
Have you ever tried skinning on skis going
uphill with skins on skis?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, so Lance Armstrong's
a good buddy and he moved out of Austin to
Aspen a few years ago, and I keep giving him
crap for it.
I'm like, "Dude, why did you leave?
Why leave?"
He's like, "Yeah, it's tough."
Especially in the winter because he's a summer
sport guy, but this is his form of winter
exercise.
Having him describe it to me, I'm like, "Yeah,
I can see that.
That sounds pretty awesome, actually."
Tim Ferriss: So this, Peter, but people listening
may not, I historically am about as far from
an endurance athlete as you could possibly
be in the sense that if you look at my sports
career, such as it was, it's all optimizing
for trying to win very quickly within three
to five minutes generally.
Anything close to extended exercise has always
been rightly and probably wrongly punishment
in my view.
I just have really disliked it, which means
I've gravitated towards weight training, things
like that.
Skinning and rucking are the two things that
have changed that.
My body, including my low back pain and so
on, feels so much better when I am doing skinning
and rucking.
I will say with the rucking, and I don't know
what your setup looks like, but I really benefit
from having a waist strap.
There are rucking backpacks out there that
do not have a waist strap, and I find those
can cause some back pain if I have either
too much weight, use them for too long or
both, but —
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, can I make a shameless
plug for my friend Jason McCarthy's company?
GORUCK?
Tim Ferriss: Please.
Yeah, please.
Dr. Peter Attia: I have no affiliation, but
I love Jason and I love the company.
So yeah, the GORUCK is the way to go here.
Again, you just need a backpack with weight,
but if you want to invest in it, they make
amazing packs.
You can buy these bolt on waistbands that
allow you to support because I'm like you,
I like to have 80 percent of the weight on
my hips and virtually none of it on my shoulders.
I don't even link up the little strap across
my chest because I want to be able to breathe
fully.
So I'm very light on the shoulders, incredibly
heavy on the hips and their packs and the
weights that come with them.
Just make this a very elegant solution.
Yeah, totally agree.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, Yeah.
So GORUCK.
I also use GORUCK, so I'll give them a plug,
I don't know the founders, but ended up honing
in on GORUCK.
I will say also the breathing component, aside
from the loading distribution that you just
men mentioned, one of the benefits that I
find of rucking versus, say, a weighted vest,
which are quite popular in the CrossFit communities
and so on, is where you are bearing the weight
and also the ability to breathe.
So those would be two advantages.
I'm sure there's a lot to be said for the
weighted vests as well.
Although funny, I'll tell you, Peter, I don't
know if I've ever told you this.
This was probably 2009, 2010, I decided I
was going to try weighted vests and I was
like, "This is going to be fantastic.
I can't wait."
So I bought this monster, which was loaded
up, it looked like a suicide bomber vest,
you just had all these — they looked like
canisters full of weight.
Dr. Peter Attia: How much did they weigh?
Tim Ferriss: Well, okay, I'll get there.
So I thought to myself, it's just walking.
At that point, I was very seriously, and I
know this is not winning any records, but
for me, it was a lot.
I was probably 180 and I was deadlifting 475
for reps, which is as high as I got.
I thought to myself, I walk all the time,
let me get — I think it was a hundred pound
vest.
So I get this hundred-pound vest and I put
it on and I decide to go for a leisurely two
or three-mile walk and I get a mile out and
I'm like, "I can't carry this thing, I'm just
going to collapse into a puddle on the sidewalk."
So I had to leave the vest on the sidewalk,
this is in The Mission in San Francisco and
go back to my house to get a car to come get
it.
I thought to myself, if anybody steals this
thing, they deserve to have it.
Not surprisingly, the weight vest did not
move.
It stayed exactly where it was.
So yeah, rucking, I suggest rucking and start
later than —
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, I recommend people
start with a sixth to a quarter of their body
weight.
Tim Ferriss: You'll end up dropping.
It's a good chance you'll end up dropping
it somewhere.
Dr. Peter Attia: Truthfully, I think Michael
Easter, who's written about this extensively
in his book The Comfort Crisis, which if your
listeners haven't read that, not that we're
trying to give them more books to read, but
The Comfort Crisis, I can't recommend highly
enough.
I think he said that even the military right
now thinks that you don't really need to go
above a third of your body weight.
So let gravity help you more than that.
But sort of anywhere from a sixth to a third,
your body weight is probably the sweet spot.
Tim Ferriss: Where I've ended up, and this
will make me sound weak maybe, but is right
around 45.
In some cases I've added a bit more weight,
but I probably weigh 175 right now.
45, and then focusing on inclines, basically
just going for the sort of geographical altitude,
or not even necessarily altitude, but the
incline challenge rather than slapping on
a ton of weight and walking on flatter ground.
What are some other for you, crux — we've
spoken about strength, we've spoken about
VO2 max, just so I can maybe explicitly explain
why I've spent, and we have spent some time
on this, it's because these are not purely
— the implications are not purely muscular.
Maybe this is a place to talk about what you
have learned about neurodegenerative disease,
and specifically, perhaps, Alzheimer's.
Because I think this will all tie in and show
people that the sort of Cartesian duality
of body and mind is really illusory, could
you speak to that?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, I think that probably
the first time I took a hard look at this
would've been 2014, maybe 2015.
At the time, I had one analyst, his name was
Dan Palenchar, look at this in detail.
God, it was probably a six to nine-month project.
it was a really, really exhaustive look at
the literature and the deepest dive we could
do at the time of what do we know about the
prevention of Alzheimer's disease?
So again, we started with a very bold hypothesis,
which we were not alone in, but most people
thought was crazy, which was that these diseases
have some degree of prevention.
There is a way to prevent these to some extent,
maybe not completely, but luck is not the
only thing, or bad luck is not the only thing
that is driving these diseases.
We have some control.
So to make a very long story short, after
Dan kind of went through all of this analysis
and after analysis after analysis, the thing
that stood out above everything else was the
benefit of exercise.
I just sort of told Dan to go back to the
drawing board.
I was kind of like, "Dan, I think you screwed
this analysis up, buddy.
There's zero chance that exercise is actually
the best thing here.
Are you going to now tell me that chicken
soup is the best thing for colds?
I wanted some insight here.
I didn't want some stupid platitude," but
it turned out Dan was right and I was wrong.
So I think the data are pretty unambiguous.
In fact, I'm doing a podcast on this.
I don't know, by the time this one's out,
it might be out.
I don't know, I don't know.
But I've got a podcast coming out on brain
health and here we are back again now with
many more analysts and much more tools at
our disposal to understand the literature
and still exercise remains the most important
modifiable behavior we have to reduce the
risk of Alzheimer's disease and probably Parkinson's
and Lewy body dementia, by the way.
So I can't say that for every single neurodegenerative
disease, I don't have any real insight into
how you prevent Lou Gehrig's disease, which
is an absolutely horrific disease that is
fortunately much more rare.
But when it comes to the big three — Alzheimer's,
Parkinson's, Lewy body dementia — exercise,
exercise and exercise matter, and part of
that has to do with movement reserve.
So when you think about Lewy body and Parkinson's,
these are primarily movement disorders.
So they're kind of on a spectrum.
So you've got Parkinson's at one end, pure
movement disorder, a little bit of cognitive.
Lewy body kind of bit of both.
Then Alzheimer's, much more cognitive, having
a higher movement reserve and having a higher
cognitive reserve are protective.
So people —
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by movement
reserve?
Just greater range of motion ability?
So spectrum of movement patterns that they
can sustain?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
The greater physical capacity.
So people who are really good dancers, who
are really good at doing complicated, coordinated,
problem-solving things with their body who
have kinesthetic awareness, they're going
to have a much slower decline even when diagnosed
with Parkinson's disease, for example.
So we want our cognitive reserve high, we
want our movement reserve high.
Then on the other side of that, you get the
sort of hormonal vascular metabolic benefits
that come from the actual exercise.
So one is the benefits you get from being
in the state, one is the benefits you get
accruing the state.
Tim Ferriss: Could you expand a bit on the
hormonal effects and otherwise, I mean, I
think this is probably just because it has
words in the acronym that I like, but brain-derived
neurotrophic factor, et cetera?
To what extent can you weight some of these
factors?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
BDNF is one of the most important.
Yeah, I don't know I that I could tell you
a relative weighting, but certainly BDNF is
a very important one.
So it's a very important growth factor for
neurons.
But also, of course, when you think about
the metabolic effects and the hormonal effects
that come from what is exercise doing to cortisol
levels?
What is exercise doing with glucose and insulin
I mean, we see an unbelievably strong association
between type two diabetes and Alzheimer's
disease.
Well, again, here's an example of where Medicine
3.0 I think gives you a little bit more confidence
to make the extension, which is, look, if
type two diabetes is bad, having insulin resistance
without type two diabetes is also probably
bad.
Therefore, we want to take all steps possible
to maximize insulin sensitivity, glucose disposal,
all of these things that fit under the bucket
of metabolic health.
Again, exercise is not unique in its ability
to act on those things.
Nutrition absolutely does as well, but boy,
does exercise have a profound effect on those
things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Let's talk about training the trainer, maybe.
By that, I mean the vast majority of people
listening to this will not be able to work
with you or a practice like yours.
What types of requests can they make of their
physicians?
What types of tests might they ask for?
This may be a clumsily worded question, but
how can they make their doctor and their health
plan per se better?
Are there any recommendations you have?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, look, I think that
it kind of comes back a little bit to your
medical literacy question at the outset, which
is, I think part of it is also just being
a bit more clear about what your objectives
are when you're finding a doctor and understanding
a little bit about what their style is.
I mean, asking them what is their philosophy
on something?
How much time do you spend learning about
things that you did not learn in medical school?
I go back to something I said earlier, which
was, there's almost nothing I do today, Tim,
that I learned in medical school.
I can't think of one thing.
It's not because what I learned in medical
school wasn't valuable.
Maybe that's the wrong example, by the way,
let's be a little more less glib.
If I look at the physicians in my practice
who trained in internal medicine and ask the
question, "What did you learn in residency
that you're using today?"
The answer's probably like 10 to 15 to maybe
20 percent, max.
So where did that other 80 percent come from?
I'm arguing that if you want to participate
in Medicine 3.0, you have to be able to learn
outside of your training.
I think that's a discussion that should be
had very deliberately and not obliquely.
So I think understanding where they sit on
prevention, understand how they're educating
themselves, what are they reading, what are
they learning?
If the answer is, "Hey, it's not a good fit,
great.
Better to find that out before you jump in."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
As we're talking about this, two things came
to mind, and please feel free to dismantle
this, but the first is to be able to assess
medical literacy, you have to have a certain
base level of medical literacy yourself.
So I would say kind of step number one is
developing a working vocabulary and also frameworks,
many of which you provide in Outlive, such
that you can actually assess other people
to some extent.
That's kind of step one.
The second is that if we think about many
Western-trained, or I shouldn't say Western-trained.
Physicians who are sort of schooled in a Western
paradigm as those focused on the sort of addressing
of disease rather than prevention of disease,
broadly speaking.
May be unfair to paint so broadly, but let's
stick with that for a minute, that as you
think of your healthcare, it goes beyond just
your primary care physician and could very
well and probably should include people like
exercise physiologists or people who are trainers,
given how much overlap and integration we've
discussed in the course of our conversation.
It just occurred to me that — this I think
is quite true, that it's a lot easier.
Not that you shouldn't look for concierge
doctors if you have the means and that's a
possibility, by all means do that.
But you can find excellent, excellent strength
coaches, I would say, much more easily than
you may be able to get yourself into a economic
position where you can afford concierge medicine
and the payoffs.
I'm not saying they're comparable, but the
payoffs of having a good strength coach or
an endurance coach go a long way.
Those came to mind also.
Let's just say they're asking these questions
of their doctors.
They find a doctor.
Are there any particular recommendations you
would have?
A couple of things come to mind that I have
in my notes here related to tests to request.
For instance, I don't know where you stand
now on GRAIL, which I guess would be considered
a liquid biopsy, right?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Scans like Prenuvo for instance,
and perhaps more intelligent approach to family
history is something that I know you cover
in the book.
Would you like to speak to anything that might
fall in that category of things to consider
requesting?
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, we think it's really
important to be testing, as I said, APOE is
one thing for sure.
We really do want to know that genotype.
And again, if you believe that Alzheimer's
disease has some element of prevention baked
into it, then knowing that you're high risk
should be a valuable thing to understand.
When it comes to understanding cardiovascular
disease, we care deeply about apoB.
apoB, again being a more important metric
than LDL cholesterol, or non HDL cholesterol,
or HDL cholesterol.
This apoB is the concentration of all atherogenic
particles, so includes all the HDLs, VLDLs,
et cetera.
Also, knowing LPa, which is a genetically
determined very high-risk particle that while
it can't be modified, will allow you to understand
how much more you need to optimize, for example,
apoB.
So knowing LPa, knowing apoB, knowing APOE.
I think there are other biomarkers obviously,
that we care deeply about uric acid, homocysteine
insulin, liver function tests.
Cystatin C is one that I think is largely
underappreciated.
So most doctors are using creatinine as the
measure of kidney function.
Creatinine is a joke, actually.
I, actually, at some point, I wish I had the
time, and maybe I'll make the time to do a
deep dive into how it became the defacto gold
standard for measuring and estimating glomerular
filtration rate.
It's an absolute atrocity.
For a person who's very low in muscle mass,
it really overestimates kidney function.
For a person with high muscle mass or who's
just exercised, it really underestimates kidney
function, but it virtually never correctly
estimates kidney function.
Whereas Cystatin C, which is another blood
test, probably costs a few more dollars, but
certainly not much.
It might be the difference of $1 versus $7
or something, completely more accurate and
unlinked to these issues of muscle mass.
Tim Ferriss: How do you spell Cystatin C?
Dr. Peter Attia: C-Y-S-T-A, Cystat, as it
sounds phonetically, I couldn't do the spelling
bee.
But it's C-Y.
Tim Ferriss: People will find it on Google.
Dr. Peter Attia: C-Y-S.
Yeah, exactly.
Don't ask me to spell anything longer than
"ah."
Tim Ferriss: All right.
How about on the early cancer screening side?
Dr. Peter Attia: Well, again, I think that
cancer chapter is probably a very long chapter
for a reason, but I think one of the big takeaways
on that chapter is the overwhelming evidence
that treating cancers when they are detected
early has significantly better outcomes than
treating the exact same cancer later on down
the line, even using the same cocktail of
drugs.
I think the two examples in the book I use
are that of colon cancer and breast cancer,
and looking at, for example, using the FOLFOX
regimen of chemotherapy to treat a patient
with adjuvant treatment, meaning, so a person
that had a stage two or stage three colon
cancer that is resected and at least surgically,
you don't see any gross disease, they just
have microscopic disease.
You treat those people with the FOLFOX chemo
regimen, which is a multi-drug regimen, and
you compare that to people who have metastatic
disease, the outcomes are vastly different.
In the latter group, nobody's going to survive
for 10 years and very few of them will make
it five years.
In the former group, 80 plus percent are going
to survive 10 years.
Go through the similar example of breast cancer.
The point here is the fewer tumor cells you
have, the fewer, the smaller the burden of
cancer, the fewer the mutations, the fewer
the escape mechanisms that are in place to
evade the immune system, the more likely you
are to survive treatment.
And therefore, until we figure out ways to
completely eliminate cancer, which I don't
think are going to happen anytime soon, we
have to take a much more aggressive posture
towards screening and acknowledge, by the
way, the downside of that.
There's a significant downside to more aggressive
screening, but if you can come to grips with
that, you have a better chance of beating
cancer by far.
And to your question, now, GRAIL becomes one
of the tools we would think about doing that.
GRAIL is a company, I guess it's currently
or now probably owned by Illumina, and it
uses something called cell-free DNA.
It takes a blood, couple tubes of blood and
looks in there for tiny, tiny, tiny amounts
of DNA that are out of the cell.
Most of the DNA, Tim, if you went and did
a DNA test and they took blood, they would
take the DNA out of cells in your blood, they'd
break down red blood cells and white blood
cells and take the DNA.
But this technique looks at all the DNA which
is not in cells, which is a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of a percent.
They look at that DNA and by looking at the
methylation pattern of it, so these little
methyl groups that are stuck to it, they impute
two things.
One, is cancer likely to be present, yes or
no?
And if yes, can we figure out what organ it
is?
Where did it come from?
These tests have a relatively low sensitivity,
meaning if a cancer is present, their ability
to detect it is not that high.
They have a very high specificity, which means
if no cancer is present, they're very likely
to tell you that.
Every screening test has to be tuned towards
sensitivity versus specificity.
And this test is tuned to very high specificity,
very low sensitivity.
Knowing the sensitivity and specificity of
a diagnostic test is only slightly useful.
If you don't know the prevalence of the condition
you're testing for, which is called the pretest
probability, you can't actually impute what's
called positive and negative predictive value.
In other words, what you really want to know
when you look at a diagnostic test before
you take it is if it's positive, how likely
is it that I have the condition?
If it's negative, how likely is it that I
don't have the condition?
That's positive and negative predictive value
respectively.
And you can only answer that question when
not only the sensitivity and specificity,
but what your pretest probability is.
And if you don't know that, you would just
say, "Well, what's the prevalence of the condition
in where I'm looking?"
When you take cancer screening in a general
population, the prevalence is very low.
That'd be one percent, two percent.
100 people that walk into for a random cancer
screening, you wouldn't expect more than one
or two of them have cancer.
With a low sensitivity and a high specificity
test you have, if you do the math, you'll
see, very low positive predictive value and
very high negative predictive value.
And for that reason, I think initially was
not blown away by the test because of how
low the sensitivity was.
For low stage cancers, like stage one and
stage two, the sensitivity was like 20 percent.
And that's the metric that I cared most about.
I don't really care about your sensitivity
at detecting stage four cancer.
We've blown it if we're waiting until that
point.
What is very interesting to me though, is
when you start to look at this by histology,
and this to me is interesting.
If you look at all breast cancer, the stage
one, stage two sensitivity for detection is
20-ish percent.
But if you look at hormone negative breast
cancer, it's 75 percent.
If you look at hormone positive cancer, it's
20 percent, basically.
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by hormone negative
and positive?
Dr. Peter Attia: One of the most important
ways that we identify breast cancer is by
its hormone profile.
Is it estrogen, progesterone, and/or HER2
neu positive?
Triple negative breast cancer has the worst
prognosis.
A breast cancer that does not express the
progesterone estrogen or HER2 neu receptors
has the worst outcome.
It's the most aggressive breast cancer.
And those cancers even at the same stage are
far more detectable.
They have a 75 percent sensitivity in low
stage cancer.
This tells us that we need to think of liquid
biopsies in a very different way from how
we think about "anatomic screening."
A mammogram or an MRI or an ultrasound are
agnostic to the properties of the cancer.
They are simply looking at its presence and
size.
What this liquid biopsy might be giving us
a window into is the behavior of a cancer.
Why is it that a triple negative, I have a
75 percent chance of — I'm using the terminology
looser, but let's just say I got a 75 percent
chance of catching it in the bloodstream even
at an early stage.
Whereas if it's triple positive, which has
a much better outcome, I'm not going to catch
it very likely at that stage.
Might it be that because the latter is not
that lethal and therefore it's not shedding,
and the former is much more lethal and that's
why the cancer is spreading?
I think it's super early days on this, and
I think these cancer screening is definitely
one of the most contentious things that I
probably talk about in the book, because I
do take, I think, a very different view from
the mainstream, which is that we have to do
this aggressively, we have to do this early.
I mean, I'm just 50 years old.
I'm three colonoscopies in at 50.
To me, just as it's unacceptable I think,
to die of cardiovascular disease in the year
2023, I think it's unacceptable to die of
colon cancer, and yet colon cancer is the
third leading cause of cancer death.
Tim Ferriss: I will just say, I'm not going
to name names, but a friend of mine put off
colonoscopy for a few years, older guy and
—
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah, I know who you're talking
about.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, stage four.
Early counts, early counts a lot.
And I'm just going to leave a couple of gingerbread
trails for folks because I do want them to
pick up the book.
I mean, there's so much, we couldn't even
scratch the surface in our conversation.
But the contrast between say, CT angiogram
over calcium score or calcium scan, I mean,
there's so much we could dig into, immunotherapy
and many other things.
But what I'd like to do, you'll probably get
a kick out of this.
Number one, I think you have some of the best
chapter names I've seen in a long time.
I want to give you credit where credit is
due.
And then where I think I'd like to go is to
ask you about —
Dr. Peter Attia: By the way, some of those
might be — Bill Gifford might deserve some
of the credit, my co-author.
I was really struggling for some chapters
with quotes.
As you probably noticed, each chapter has
a quote, and I think Bill probably came up
with three quarters of them.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, nice.
Dr. Peter Attia: I was really struggling with
the quotes because I had some that were okay,
but he would always come through in the end
with a better one.
Tim Ferriss: Well, credit to Bill.
But what I'd like to do, just to give people
a lay of the land is actually, this is going
to sound ridiculous, but just read through
these briefly.
And then what I'd like to talk about is how
and why you decided to include the chapter
"The High Price of Ignoring Emotional Health."
If you bear with me here, I'll just do a little
recital.
Chapter one, "The Long Game from Fast Death
to Slow Death."
And I'm not going to give the chapter numbers,
I'm just going to go through these.
"Medicine 3.0: Rethinking Medicine for the
Age of Chronic Disease."
We touched on this briefly.
"Objective Strategy Tactics: A Roadmap for
Reading This Book."
"Centenarians" — this is coming into part
two — "The Older You Get, the Healthier
You've Been."
"Eat Less, Live Longer?
The Science of Hunger and Health."
"One Disease to Rule Them All."
"The Crisis of Abundance."
"The Ticker: Confronting and Preventing Heart
Disease, the Deadliest Killer on the Planet."
That's my chapter, as you know.
If anything is going to kill me that isn't
an accident, it is probably heart disease.
"The Runaway Cell: New Ways to Address the
Killer That is Cancer."
"Chasing Memory: Understanding Alzheimer's
Disease."
Also something in my family and other neurodegenerative
diseases.
Part three, we're rounding the bend here,
coming into home here.
"Thinking Tactically: Building a Framework
of Principles That Work For You."
"Exercise" Nature's Longevity Drug."
"Training 101: Training for the Centenarian
Decathlon," which for those long-term, long-term
podcast listeners, that may sound familiar,
and it's certainly been refined and developed
in the form that you find in this book.
"The Gospel of Stability."
Let me try that — the fact that I stumbled
on that is funny.
"The Gospel of Stability: Relearning How to
Move to Prevent Injury."
Jesus Christ, Tim Ferriss, hold on one second.
Pull it together.
"The Gospel of Stability: Relearning How to
Move to Prevent Injury."
"Nutrition 3.0: You Say Potato, I Say Nutritional
Biochemistry."
That's the most Peter thing I've ever read.
"Putting Nutritional Biochemistry into Practice:
New Rules for Changing the Way You Eat."
"The Awakening: Tap into the Power of Sleep."
Then last but not least, "Work in Progress:
The High Price of Ignoring Emotional Health."
Why the last chapter?
Dr. Peter Attia: I'll tell you something funny.
When I had an early draft of the book, I shared
it with a mutual friend of ours, Hugh Jackman,
and Hugh read it, and his only feedback was
that should be the first chapter.
And Hugh had a really solid argument for why
that was the case.
The publisher absolutely said, "No chance
in hell."
And so it was either nowhere or at the very
end of the book.
Look, I think that this was the hardest chapter
to write, unquestionably.
It's the 17th chapter that has very little
to do with the other 16 for reasons I won't
necessarily explain here.
But it's a very different format.
It's a very different structure and it tells
a very different story.
But look, I think for some people it might
be the most important chapter in the book.
And I think for others it might be totally
irrelevant.
But that was a risk I think that was worth
taking.
And I'll just say this, I think you alluded
to this earlier on several occasions, longevity
without health span is the greatest curse
in the world.
To live a long life and to suffer is not to
live.
And that suffering, that loss of health span
can be cognitive, it can be physical, and
it can be emotional.
And that last one is so squishy that it's
hard to talk about in a medical book, but
that chapter is basically my way of trying
to do that.
Tim Ferriss: I just want to give some, if
you don't mind, I'll give a teaser.
Now, there's a lot to this chapter.
We're not going to dig into all of it, but
maybe we could start with, and we won't spend
too much time as I'm watching the lighting
in the sun and the moon and the stars changing
your video, because I know we've been going
for a while, but are you open to discussing
the 47 affirmations that you had to write
and the context, a little bit of the context
around that?
Because I think a lot of people listening
to this will identify with certainly that
particular instance of your experience.
Dr. Peter Attia: Yeah.
Boy, it's hard to explain that without explaining
where I was when I was being asked to do that.
But —
Tim Ferriss: Sure, whatever you'd like to.
Dr. Peter Attia: Again, the sun is low.
Let's just say I was in a rehabilitation center
where one of my homework assignments on the
first day was to write an affirmation for
each year I'd been alive.
At the time I was 47, this was three years
ago.
So it was, you've got to come up with 47 things
to say about yourself that are positive.
And I couldn't come up with more than a few.
I was stuck at four or five until the 19th
day.
Then I really had an enormous breakthrough
that honestly, in the book is — I don't
devote a lot of real estate to it, as profound
as it is.
But I think if you're a person reading this
who's been where I'm taking you will understand
it.
But I think once I reached that point, once
I had that breakthrough, as I described in
the book, I was able to write the remaining
43 of them in 20 minutes.
Those 47 affirmations then became a very big
part of my recovery contract.
And for a period of about six months, I would
read those twice a day, every day, standing
in front of a mirror, which sounds very Stuart
Smalley or whatever that character's name
was.
What was his name?
Smiley?
Tim Ferriss: It was something like that.
"I'm good enough," and —
Dr. Peter Attia: "I'm good enough."
Tim Ferriss: "Gosh darn it, people like me."
Dr. Peter Attia: That's right.
But I think for my problems, this was such
an important step, this fake it until you
make it.
I was able to basically use that in my — the
term fake it until you make it has such a
negative connotation from Silicon Valley and
companies like Theranos.
But in psychology, it can actually be pretty
valuable.
If you start to say something enough, you
will believe it.
And we think about that a lot in the negative
but it works also in the positive.
And I think that in some ways, that one exercise
became a very important brick in the wall
of fundamentally altering my view of myself
and fundamentally altering the stories I told
myself.
Tim Ferriss: And I must say, as someone who
was there in your life for that period, and
also watching the steps that you took, including
what you just described, I am so glad that
you included the chapter in this book because
I think a lot of people who would like to
optimize lifespan and health span nonetheless
find it easier to think about the maybe hard
measurable edges of something that is physical
versus that which is currently giving them
the most suffering, which is some lack of
equilibrium or a set of proper, I shouldn't
say proper, constructive lenses through which
to view life and themselves.
I think it's a real gift and not one without,
I'm sure, some trepidation on your part to
include this in the book.
I just wanted to commend and thank you for
including that.
Because I think it'll help a lot of people.
And so I hope you feel good about it.
Dr. Peter Attia: Thank you so much.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I hope you feel good about
it, Peter.
Peter, we talked about a lot.
The sun has come.
The sun is gone.
Is there anything else that you would like
to mention before we close any requests to
people?
The book is Outlive: The Science and Art of
Longevity.
I never say this, long-term listeners will
know this, go get the book.
This is a very, very solid book that many
years have gone into, not just in the writing,
but in the living and experimenting and refining
and changing of mind that is reflected in
the adaptability and principles in the book.
I do recommend everybody check out the book.
Of course, earlymedical.com.
Peterattiamd.com.
There are many other places on Instagram,
@PeterAttiaMD.
Is there anything else that you'd like to
mention, Peter, before we wrap up?
Dr. Peter Attia: No, other than just to really
thank people.
I think there's a lot of noise out there in
the world today.
And I think that anyone who's going to buy
this book and devote the time to read it or
listen to it on the audiobook, this is not
a two-crapper.
This is not a book you're going to read on
the toilet in taking two craps.
I just want to thank everybody who —
Tim Ferriss: Never heard that expression.
Dr. Peter Attia: Oh, I think of all books
as how many craps.
Every book is like, it's a four-crapper, it's
a two-crapper.
It's an amazing honor.
Little things I've been doing for the book
prep that would've ordinarily annoyed me to
no end, haven't annoyed me at all, because
I'm realizing that it is a special thing that
you have a relationship with someone you're
not necessarily meeting but they're doing
something that is giving of themselves, which
is taking the time to read this thing.
And in exchange, you're giving them something
that's hopefully valuable.
Anyway, thank you for having me on the show,
Tim.
And thanks for people who are going to maybe
go out and get this thing.
Tim Ferriss: All right, guys, it's no two-crapper.
That's my quote on the back of the book.
You'll find it featured prominently on Amazon.
And Peter, congratulations, man.
I know this has been a long time coming.
I'm excited for you.
I am even more excited for the people who
will read this and hopefully derive from it
some clarity and focus amidst an overwhelming
amount of noise and bullshit out there.
I do see this as a very strong signal in a
sea of noise, so I encourage people to check
it out.
Outlive: The Science and Art of Longevity.
Dr. Peter Attia, nice to see you, man, and
to be continued in person soon.
Maybe we'll have those two drinks a piece
with some red wine and some nice selects of
axis deer from your freezer.
And best of luck with the launch, man.
Thanks for making the time.
Dr. Peter Attia: Thanks man, appreciate it.
Thank you so much.